ich habe daher den Botschafter
eingestellt und wir haben am Montag für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland im
Menschenrechtsrat in Genf ganz deutlich
klargestellt die iranischen Behörden
müssen ihr brutales Vorgehen gegen die
Demonstranten und Demonstranten
unverzüglich einstellen der vor der Tod
von Gina masamini und der vielen
weiteren Menschen die bei den
Demonstrationen getötet wurden gehört
dringend aufgeklärt
und im Kreis der EU-Staaten im Kreis der
EU-Staaten tue ich gerade alles dafür
dass wir Sanktionen auf den Weg bringen
können gerade jetzt ja gerade auch jetzt
wo wir weiter über das jcpoa Verhandeln
Sanktionen gegen diejenigen in Iran auf
dem Weg zu bringen die ohne Rücksicht
Frauen im Namen der Religion zu Tode
prügeln
Demonstranten erschießen
und ich sage hier auch ganz deutlich das
ist keine Einmischung in die Belange
eines anderen Landes nein hierzu hat
sich der Iran wie jedes Land auf der
Welt verpflichtet unter anderem im
Internationalen Pakt über bürgerliche
und politische Rechte
und bei allem Respekt vor kulturellen
und religiösen Unterschieden wenn die
Polizei wie es scheint eine Frau zu Tode
prügelt weil sie aus Sicht der
sittenwärter ihr Kopftuch nicht richtig
trägt dann hat das nichts aber auch gar
nichts mit Religion oder Kultur zu tun
dann ist das schlicht ein entsetzliches
Verbrechen und es ist wichtig dass wir
heute
fraktionsübergreifend dieses Verbrechen
so klar benennen denn ja das ist
deutsche Außenpolitik das ist deutsche
Werte geleitete feministische
Außenpolitik ich möchte an dieser Stelle
aber auch deutlich sagen eine Werte
geleitete feministische Außenpolitik
bemisst sich für mich als Politikerin
nicht daran wie laut oder oft man
twittert sondern eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik ist oftmals mühevoll harte
Arbeit hinter den Kulissen denn es
bedeutet vor allen Dingen Strukturen
sexistische Machtstrukturen aufzubrechen
der Feige Mord Angina haasamini ist kein
Einzelfall sondern erst Ausdruck eines
Systems ein Machtsystem das auf Gewalt
gegenüber seinen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
auf Gewalt gegenüber seinen regionalen
Nachbarn im Zweifel auch mit
Nuklearwaffen aber eben auch auf einem
System von Erniedrigung und von Gewalt
gegenüber Frauen basiert und diese
machtsysteme die finden wir wo sexuelle
Gewalt ein Teil dieses macht und
erniedrigungssystem ist leider auch an
anderen Orten dieser Welt
bei diesen Machtsystem in der Rente ist
dass Sie wissen wenn Frauen nicht sicher
sind dann weiß jeder in einem Land das
niemand sicher ist und umgekehrt gilt
wenn Frauen sicher sind dann ist jeder
sicher in einer Gesellschaft und in
diesem Sinne lieber unionskolleginnen
danke ich auch für Ihren Brief den 19
von ihnen für mich geschrieben haben und
zu mehr Einsatz für Frauenrechte
auffordern ich nehme ihnen als Ausdruck
dessen liebe Frau Güler liebe Frau schön
liebe Frau Klöckner und die anderen dass
ihre Partei dass ihre Parteivorsitzende
seiner Aussage zum sozialtourismus nicht
nur korrigiert hat sondern dass die
Union uns alle gemeinsam dabei aktiv
unterstützt das feministische
Außenpolitik mehr ist als nur eine kurze
empathische Geste dass wir gemeinsam so
wie bei dieser aktuellen Stunde bereit
sind Strukturen zu verändern auch bei
uns
dass sich die Frauen in Iran ebenso wie
die ukrainischen Frauen darauf verlassen
können dass unsere Solidarität trägt
auch wenn sie uns selbst etwas
abverlangt dass Sie sich darauf
verlassen können dass unsere Solidarität
trägt wenn diese Frauen nicht mehr
überall in den Nachrichten sind sondern
dass wir gemeinsam froh und ich würde
für mich persönlich sagen auch stolz
darauf sind dass wir nicht nur zu Beginn
dieses furchtbaren russlandkrieges diese
Flüchtlinge wie manche sie nennen
aufgenommen haben sondern dass wir Sie
mit offenen Armen empfangen haben dass
wir unsere Gesellschaft für
Hunderttausende Europäerinnen aus der
Ukraine und auch unsere Sozialsysteme
geöffnet haben weil nur so können und
konnten Kommunen Lehrer Nachbarn
Familien von Tag eins alles dafür tun
dass 4
65.00054 Frauen und
352.467 Kinder zum heutigen Tag ein
Stück Sicherheit aber eben auch ein
Stück zu Hause bekommen haben und ich
sage an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich
bei feministische Außenpolitik mehr ist
als Einzelfälle ja es hilft all diesen
Frauen und Kindern so wie es allen
anderen hilft die Schutz bei uns suchen
Kontakt nach Hause zu halten mich lässt
ein Satz in diesem Krieg nicht mehr los
ein Satz seines Mädchens das elf Jahre
alt ist in einer Schule in Potsdam die
meinte bei einem der Schulbesuche zu mir
Frau bärbox sie kennen noch Herrn
silensky können Sie ihm bitte sagen ich
möchte meinem Papa wiedersehen
und ich war so froh als ich diesen
Sommer hörte dass sie für drei Wochen in
Ukraine fuhr um ihren Vater nach 176
Tagen endlich wieder in die Arme zu
nehmen aber nichts hat mich ehrlich
gesagt mehr erleichtert als ich gehört
habe dass sie zurückgekommen ist mit
ihrer Mutter und ihrem einjährigen
Bruder weil ihr zu Hause ist die Oblast
saporica und nicht alles ist derzeit
besetzt aber es ist an der Frontlinie
und ja hunderttausende werden hin und
her Reisen zwischen der Ukraine und
Deutschland bis ihr Land wieder in die
Frieden leben kann und wir werden ihn
unsere Unterstützung geben solange sie
sie brauchen weil das bedeutet für mich
feministische Außenpolitik auch dann
solide Solidarität zu zeigen wenn der
Wind einem entgegengeht das gilt für
unsere ukrainischen Nachbarn und dann
fragen Sie warum rede ich über die
Ukraine weil die Frauen im Iran müssen
sich darauf verlassen können dass wir
nicht nur jetzt an ihrer Seite stehen
werden auch morgen und übermorgen wenn
der Wind sich bei Ihnen oder auf der
Welt weiter gedreht hat unsere
Solidarität gilt für die Frauen in
Afghanistan in Belarus und im Iran denn
so furchtbar der Tod von gieren und die
Niederschlagung der Proteste im Iran ist
das ist kein Einzelfall Gina du bist
nicht gestorben dein Name ist Aufruf und
zwar weltweit dankeschön
die bundesaußenministerin Annalena
baerbock die hier zu Beginn dieser
aktuellen Stunde den Ton gesetzt hat und
die den Blick noch über den Iran hinaus
geweitet hat Anna-Lena baerbock hat zu
erneut Sanktionen gegen den Iran
gefordert neue Sanktionen und im Kreis
der EU wird sie und
wird sie anschieben dann eben über
weitere Konsequenzen zu sprechen jetzt
Annette wiedmann-mauz für die
Unionsfraktion
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber
sterben wir als dass wir weiterhin die
Erniedrigung ertragen zu diesem
existenziellen Schluss kommen Frauen im
Iran trotz Festnahmen Schlägen und
brutaler Gewalt des müller-reschims
riskieren tausende von ihnen gerade
alles ihr Leben ihre Existenz und diese
Frauen
verdienen unsere volle Solidarität und
Sie verdienen ein starkes Zeichen der
Geschlossenheit
ihre
Stimmen sind viel zu laut als das hier
überhört oder nur kleinlaut zur Kenntnis
genommen werden können denn wenn sie den
Mut haben auf die Straße zu gehen dann
dürfen doch gerade wir die wir in
Freiheit leben zu dem Schicksal von
masseamini dem Verschwinden von Milo
farhamedy die ihr Schicksal aufdeckte
oder der Inhaftierung von mehr als
1.200 Menschen wieder
Frauenrechtsaktivistin Phase Haschemi
nicht schweigen
das aber der Bundeskanzler in seiner
15-minütigen Rede vor den Vereinten
Nationen die Proteste im Iran nicht mit
einem einzigen Satz angesprochen hat es
wirklich mehr als beschämend er hätte
gerade die Anwesenheit von
Staatspräsident
reisen die
massive Zungen seines Regimes zu
verurteilen er hätte sich hinter die
vn-men Menschenrechtsdeklaration und
damit an die Seite der Protestierenden
Frauen und Männer stellen können ganz
nach dem Motto you never walk alone aber
was hat tat er er schwieg wieder einmal
und sein nachgeschobener Tweet sorry der
war dann anbelanglosigkeit nicht mehr zu
überbieten und Frau verehrte Ministerin
leider waren auch Sie zu diesem Thema
bis zum heutigen Tag öffentlich kaum
wahrnehmbar das steht im deutlichen
Widerspruch zu ihrem feministischen
Anspruch aber vor allen Dingen zu den
Erwartungen der
Frauenrechtsorganisationen unter
iranischen Zivilgesellschaft warum
eigentlich bei der Ukraine sind sie viel
empathischer und sie zeigen es und auch
bei Herrn la France finden Sie doch
sonst auch klare und deutliche Worte
das Schicksal von Maser Amina hier
zahlen im Iran im übrigen unzählige
Frauen die Tag für Tag in den Händen von
Sittenpolizei und Geheimdienst gefangen
verschleppt infaktiert vergewaltigt und
getötet werden mit dem Abstreifen des
Hijab mit dem Abschneiden ihrer Haare
zeigen sie der Welt und sie zeigen vor
allen Dingen ihre Stärke sie zeigen ihre
Kraft sie zeigen wie ihren unbändigen
Drang nach Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung
ihr Protest ist ein Akt der Rebellion
des sich auflehnens gegen ein
islamistischen Gottesstaat gegen ein
System der Willkür und der Unterdrückung
Frauen sind die treiben die Kraft in
diesem Kulturkampf für gesellschaftliche
Veränderung die Brutalität und die Härte
mit der das Regime gegen sie vorgeht
zeigt wie sehr Despoten Frauen fürchten
die ihre Stimmen erheben und für ihre
Rechte kämpfen egal habe im Iran ob in
Afghanistan oder in Belarus ihr
Widerstand ist der Kampf für Freiheit
und Selbstbestimmung an der ganzen
Gesellschaft
und Frauen Außenpolitik ist deshalb auch
kein Rand und kein Nischenthema oder wie
oft auch gern gesagt wird es gibt doch
gerade wichtigeres nein es geht schon
längst nicht mehr darum ob wir eine
Frauen aus dem Politik brauchen nein es
geht darum mit welchen Instrumenten sie
auch wirksam wird nicht nur langfristig
sondern auch ganz konkret in akuten
Krisen und Konflikten welche Folgen
haben denn jetzt die Proteste für die
deutsche und für die europäische Politik
gegenüber dem Iran da habe ich wenig
gehört welche Konsequenzen haben Sie
denn jetzt für die Bundesregierung bei
den Verhandlungen um das nuklearabkommen
was bedeutet
frauenaußenpolitik ganz konkret im
Rahmen der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie wenn Frauen
Außenpolitik zu unserer außenpolitischen
DNA gehören soll dann muss sie doch auch
mit den Mitteln der klassischen
Außenpolitik verzahnt werden
was ist jetzt zu tun wir müssen den
Druck auf den Iran erhöhen und ihm die
Ressourcen entziehen die das
unterdrückungsregime am Laufen halten es
reicht einfach nicht wie es die EU getan
hat nur den Umgang mit den Protesten zu
kritisieren zu ihren Ursachen dann aber
höflich zu schweigen deshalb müssen
zusätzlich die Sanktionen verschärft und
ausgeweitet werden erstens ging die
Personen und Regierungsstellen die für
die Morde und des brutale Vorgehen
verantwortlich sind zweitens mit der
Ausweitung auf strategisch wichtige
Felder die USA haben bereits im Bereich
von Firmen sanktioniert die Russland mit
Drohnen beliefern die in der Ukraine
eingesetzt werden und drittens mit
Nachjustierung im digitaltechnologischen
Bereich dort wo nehme ich ansonsten die
Scheinwerfer auf das Unrecht ausgehen
die Mobilisierung und die Kommunikation
der Zivilgesellschaft wird wir müssen
alle Mittel und Wege nutzen die
Frauenrechtsbewegung im Iran zu
unterstützen dazu braucht es auch mehr
finanzielle Mittel für die regionale
Vernetzung und gerade eben nicht die von
Ihnen vorgesehenen und geplanten
Kürzungen im Haushalt des Auswärtigen
Amtes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zögern und jetzt den Punkt sind im
Feminismus keine Option handeln sie
danach
Annette wiedmann-mauz war das hier für
die cdu/cs-fraktion dass wir dieses ohne
Zweifel sehr wichtige und auch alle
bewegende Thema im Format einer
aktuellen Stunde hier behandeln das
heißt es gibt keine Zwischenfragen gibt
keine Bemerkung und auch keine
Anrechnung überzogener Redezeit auf die
Redezeit nachfolgende Rednerinnen und
Redner der einzelnen Fraktionen das
heißt aber auch denke ich dass wir hier
respektvoll miteinander umgehen und die
verabredete Redezeit von fünf Minuten
bitte einhalten so dass ich nicht
gezwungen bin dann in den Redefluss hier
einzugreifen
ich danke Ihnen für das Verständnis das
Wort hat nun die Kollegin Gabriela
Heinrich für die SPD-Fraktion die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sie haben Angst vor meinem Haar sie
haben Angst vor meiner Stimme sie haben
Angst vor meinem Körper ich als Frau
kann ein ganzes Regime verängstigen
das ist ein Zitat der iranischen
Journalistin Marie Aline Shad besser
kann man es nicht beschreiben
jetzt gerade in diesen Tagen gehen im
Iran tausende Menschen auf die Straße
sie gehen für ihre Rechte für ihre
Freiheit und für ihre Selbstbestimmung
auf die Straße und allen voran die
Frauen die auf offener Straße ihre
Schleier verbrennen für uns
unvorstellbar riskieren Sie dabei Leib
und Leben
sie nehmen es mit einem Regime auf das
mit brutaler Repression reagiert weit
über 1.000 Menschen wurden festgenommen
ungefähr 60 wurden getötet und das sind
nur die ungefähren staatlichen Angaben
in Wahrheit sind die Zahlen wohl viel
höher und all diesen mutigen Frauen und
Männern muss und gilt unsere volle
Solidarität
die Menschen im Iran sind wütend
Massa armini musste mit nur 22 Jahren
sterben und ihr Tod war der Anlass für
die aktuellen Proteste die Wurzeln der
Wut reichen aber viel tiefer es ist
nicht das erste Mal dass eine Frau von
der Sittenpolizei misshandelt wird und
es ist auch nicht das erste Mal dass auf
Proteste willkürliche Verhaftungen und
Folter folgen
und eines muss uns allen klar sein hier
geht es nicht um den hinter und ob er
falsch saß hier geht es auch nicht um
Religion hier geht es um Kontrolle über
die Körper über die Selbstbestimmung und
über die Freiheit von Frauen und
eigentlich geht es um die Freiheit im
Iran insgesamt denn nicht nur die Frauen
wünschen sich Freiheit sondern natürlich
auch Männer und sie haben eines
gemeinsam sie wählen sich gegen die
Unterdrückung
der Zwang zum Schleier ist das
sichtbarste Symbol einer systematischen
Repression die iranische Regierung macht
ihre Macht abhängig von der
Unterdrückung von Frauen weil sie Angst
hat
sie fürchtet dass jeder Art von
Lockerungen ihre Macht gefährdet
was wir hier sehen ist der
Überlebenskampf eines Systems dass ich
schon lange selbst überlebt hat und es
ist auch der Überlebenskampf des
Patriarchats
musste sterben weil sie eine Frau war
ihr tot macht einmal mehr bewusst
feministische und
menschenrechtsgeleitete Außenpolitik
sind eins denn nur in einer Gesellschaft
in der Menschenrechte für alle
gleichermaßen gelten kann es Frieden
kann es Sicherheit geben und das
bedeutet immer auch und vor allem
Freiheit
wir nehmen diese eklatanten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen nicht hin wir
verurteilen die schweren Verstöße gegen
Frauenrechte und die brutalen
Repressionen gehen demonstrierender
Menschen die er Recht auf
Versammlungsfreiheit wahrnehmen dürfen
nicht willkürlich inhaftiert werden
nirgendwo auf der Welt
und das müssen wir der Regierung im Iran
deutlich machen und das tun wir auch wir
fordern den Iran auf sofort eine
unabhängige Untersuchung zuzulassen um
diesen Fall restlos aufzuklären und es
ist gut das Außenminister und bärbock
das Thema in den Frauen
Menschenrechtsrat bringt mit unseren
Partnern in der EU werden wir jetzt über
weitere Konsequenzen sprechen und dazu
gehören auch gezielte Sanktionen gegen
Verantwortlichen
wir signalisieren dem Iran wir stehen
fest an der Seite der Menschen die für
ihre Rechte eintreten und wir stehen
fest an der Seite der Familie Amini
dort nannte man mother die
Außenministerin hat es gesagt bei ihrem
kurdischen Namen Gina
iranische Behörden erkennen kurdische
Namen aber nicht an auch das ist ein
Werkzeug staatlicher Unterdrückung auf
dinaminis Grabstein steht du bist nicht
gestorben und sinngemäß dein Name ist
ein Symbol und ich füge hinzu ein Symbol
auch für uns für Freiheit und für
Menschenrechte vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Jürgen
braun für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
nach biblischen Zeugnissen die Skyros
der zweite die unter den Babyloniern
verschleppten Juden in der angestammtes
Land zurückkehren die persischen Könige
ermöglichten es Ihnen den zerstörten
jerusalema Tempel wieder aufzubauen und
nach den eigenen Gesetzen und geboten zu
leben nur in wenigen Imperien genossen
die Juden im Verlauf der Jahrhunderte so
große Freiheiten wie unter den Persern
man schrieb das Jahr
539 vor Christi Geburt damals gab es
keinen Islam
heute lehnt sich das stolze persische
Volk Erbe eines der größten Reiche der
Weltgeschichte gegen die kulturfremde
Herrschaft der Mullahs auf eine junge
Frau die 22-Jährige machste Amini wird
vor zwei Wochen auf den Straßen Teherans
von der sogenannten Sittenpolizei
verhaftet nicht weil sie keinen Kopftuch
getragen hat nein sie wurde verhaftet
weil sie nicht das richtige Kopftuch
getragen haben soll sie soll abgeführt
und zu einem sogenannten
Orientierungskurs gebracht worden sein
später wird sie mit inneren Blutungen
ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert zwei Tage
darauf ist sie tot bei den
anschließenden Protesten in etlichen
Städten werden mehr als 70 weitere
Menschen getötet hunderte misshandelt
von den brutalen Herrschern der Mullahs
diese Toten haben eine Vorgeschichte sie
führt direkt ins Herz der europäischen
Linken als der ayatollak comeni in einem
Pariser Vorort im Exil saß pilgerten
linke 68er in Scharen zu ihm sie machten
ihn erst bekannt comeni kehrte nach der
Flucht des letzten Schah in den Irans
zurück er schaltete seine liberalen und
sozialistischen Konkurrenten aus Gummis
macht Ergreifung ist eine der größten
Katastrophen des letzten Jahrhunderts
Exil Iraner sind entsetzt über das
deutsche Verhalten gegenüber dem Islam
Löschung islamkritischer Postings voka
radikal Feminismus transpopaganda und
währenddessen werden im Iran Frauen und
Schwule von Islamisten umgebracht Zitat
mit eurem Selbst hören Sie bitte den
Menschen aus dem Iran zu mit eurem
selbstgerechten Einsatz gegen die
vermeintliche Islamophobie und er stützt
ihr nur die Sklavenhalter und Peiniger
unserer Heimat so der Weckruf einer
jungen exileranerin in Cicero
die grüne Regierungspartei sollte
angesichts der aktuellen protestet den
Mund nicht voll nehmen es war der
erzgrüne Joschka Fischer der in der
linksradikalen Zeitschrift
pflasterstrand die Islamische Revolution
mit den Worten pries sie richte sich
gegen das Eindringen des kommunistischen
des konsumistischen das Eindringen des
konsumistischen Atheismus der westlichen
Industriegesellschaft der
be hier als Außenminister die
noch in dümpele Schnapsidee eines
unwürdigen atomabkommens mit diesem
Staat vorangetrieben hat und es war die
damalige grüne Vorsitzende Claudia Roth
eine selbst ernannte Feministin die den
iranischen Botschafter mit High Five
begrüßt hat nämlich es trifft auf die
SPD zu ihr Bundespräsident Steinmeier
verschickte im Namen seiner Landsleute
Glückwunsch Telegramme anlässlich des
Jahrestags der islamischen Revolution
in Artikel 3 der iranischen Verfassung
wird eine Außenpolitik auf der Grundlage
der islamischen Maßstäbe vorgeschrieben
und wie diese Werte gebundene
Außenpolitik aussieht das wissen wir zur
Genüge die Islamische Republik war
niemals auch nicht unter den
vermeintlich gemäßigten Reformen um
rohani eine
stabilitätsgarant für die Region sie war
und ist im Gegenteil der wichtigste
Finanzier von Tod und Terror im Nahen
Osten
nachdem sich die Mullahs den
benachbarten Irak unter den Nagel
gerissen hatten setzten sie ihren
Einfluss ein um islamistische medizen im
Jemen und den Gasern mit Geld und Waffen
zu versorgen seit Neuestem liefert der
Iran kamikazedonen nach Russland die
Shahid heißen ein Shahid dass das ein
Kämpfer des Jihad Shahid bedeutet nichts
anderes als
Selbstmordattentäter sie waren ja sehr
erfolgreich und zwar Verhinderung des
des Islamismus und Terrorismus von Cador
mit ihren
is-sympathisanten die bei ihnen gelernt
haben ja super ja Frau kador sie gerade
sie gerade tut mir leid ja sie gerade
müssen jetzt sollten mal lieber
schweigen zu dem Thema Shahid bedeutet
nichts anderes als Selbstmordattentäter
und etliche iranische Politiker und
Generäle leugnen nicht einmal Israel
vernichten zu wollen die Bundesregierung
kann sich nicht mehr herausreden dass
die Menschen im Iran auf die Straße auf
der Straße sterben hat sehr wohl mit den
Frauen und menschenverachtenden Islam zu
tun und es hat auch mit den jahrelangen
Beschwichtigung von links zu tun vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
im Deutschen Bundestag sitzen unter
anderem zwei Abgeordnete die gerade auch
nebeneinander sozusagen saßen in den
Reihen hier der Abgeordneten die Regie
hat das schon mal eingefangen das ist
nämlich ein Hesse mit iranischen Wurzeln
das ist auch mit nuripur der
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen und es ist
ein Rheinländer mit iranischen Wurzeln
der jetzt ans Rednerpult geht das ist
nämlich der Generalsekretär der FDP
bijanji
meine Damen und Herren
Massa Amini eine
22-jährige junge Frau wurde von der
iranischen Sittenpolizei ermordet eine
junge Frau die ihr ganzes Leben vor sich
hatte wurde mit Gewalt aus dem Leben
gerissen
schuld daran ist ein Regime das
Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt und die
eigene Bevölkerung ohne Rücksicht auf
Verluste unterdrückt
heute sehen wir auf den Straßen
iranischer Städte mutige Frauen und
Männer die sich aus den Fesseln dieses
grausamen Regimes lösen wollen für ihren
Kampf für Menschenrechte
Bürgerrechte und Freiheit riskieren sie
ihr Leben
ihr Mut
erweckt die Hoffnung dass der
Zusammenbruch der schreckenherrschaft
der Islamischen Republik möglich ist es
ist gut dass der Deutsche Bundestag
in einer aktuellen Stunde über die
Ereignisse im Iran öffentlich diskutiert
wir hatten gestern eine wunderbare
Demonstration gehabt am Brandenburger
Tor und ich kann nur hier wiederholen
was ich auch dort gesagt habe
Solidarität und warme Worte reichen
nicht mehr aus
der Tod der Tod der 22-jährigen Masse
Amini hat uns auf tragische Weise vor
Augen geführt dass sie eine fundamental
andere Iran-Politik brauchen meine Damen
und Herren
während wir während wir gestern hier im
Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum diskutiert
haben haben iranische Drohnen die
Drohnen der Revolutionswächter zivile
Ziele in der autonomen Region Kurdistans
Irak angegriffen europa braucht eine
neue Iran Strategie wir können nicht
ständig
wir können nicht ständig nur über ein
atomabkommen reden während gleichzeitig
im Iran seit vielen vielen Jahren
eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
meine Damen und Herren viel zu lange ist
Europäische Union mit dem Iran einen
naiven Kuschelkurs Gefahren viel zu
lange wurde zu eklatanten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen immer und
immer wieder geschwiegen mit dieser
beschämende Haltung muss ein für alle
mal ein Ende haben meine Damen und
Herren
die Islamische Republik die Islamische
Republik ist ein Feind unseres
westlichen Wertesystems
dieses molaregime wird mit aller Härte
seine eigene Interessen verfolgen es
hemmt den Nano und Mittleren Osten in
seiner Entwicklung bedroht die Existenz
Israels und widerspricht jeglichem
Verständnis von Freiheit und Demokratie
die Islamische Republik Iran ist nicht
nur für eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
verantwortlich sondern auch für
Menschenrechtsverletzungen außerhalb des
Irans Deutschland
Deutschland und die Europäische Union
müssen gegenüber der Islamischen
Republik selbstbewusst und entschlossen
auftreten eine Neuausrichtung der
iran-strategie muss jetzt erfolgen um
den Druck zu erhöhen müssen wir
personenbezogene Sanktionen gegen
Vertreter des Regimes und
Revolutionswächter offen adressieren
und Frau Ministerin ich habe sehr
aufmerksam zugehört was Sie gesagt haben
und ich finde sie haben heute exakt die
richtigen Worte gefunden und ich bin
Ihnen sehr dankbar für Ihre Rede denn
dahin geht auch die Reise die Führung
der islamische Republik muss wissen dass
die Weltöffentlichkeit nichts vergisst
alle verantwortliche
[Applaus]
zwischen
alle Verantwortlichen die im Namen
dieses islamistischen Regimes Verbrechen
begehen müssen für ihre Handlungen zu
Rechenschaft gezogen werden meine Damen
und Herren die Freiheit
die Freiheit im Iran liegt heute in den
Händen von mutigen Menschen die ihr
Leben riskieren auf ihren Schultern ruht
die Hoffnung auf eine bessere Zukunft in
Iran im Nano Mittleren Osten und auf der
ganzen Welt meine Damen und Herren
ich muss den 1987 den Iran verlassen das
ist inzwischen das auch schon ein paar
Tage her dass in den zwischen 35 Jahre
her ich war damals 11 Jahre alt ich habe
mit meinen eigenen Augen Krieg und
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
gesehen
wer am eigenen Leib erfahren hat wie
sich Unfreiheit anfühlt wird sich
tagtäglich und unter allen Umständen für
Freiheit einsetzen das kann ich Ihnen an
dieser Stelle für
der Name massamini steht in diesen
Stunden stellvertretend vor den für den
vorstoßen Kampf gegen Ideologie
Ideologie gesteuerte und willkürliche
Unterdrückung meine Damen und Herren
das sind nicht die üblichen
Demonstrationen und streikt die wir
derzeit im Iran Erleben der Iran steht
heute am Rande einer Revolution und das
mularegime der Islamischen Republik am
Rande des Zusammenbruchs vielen Dank
der eindringliche Appell hier von vidjan
gear Saray
Generalsekretär der FDP der auch hier im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss des Bundestages
sitzt der gestern auch gesprochen hat
bei einer der zahlreichen Kundgebungen
in Berlin muss man sagen die größte
davon am Brandenburger Tor wo es eben
unter anderem darum ging Solidarität
auch mit der Frauenbewegung gerade im
Iran zu zeigen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren seit Tagen demonstrieren im Iran
Bürgerinnen und Bürger allen voran sehr
mutige und Frauen sehr mutige Frauen und
Mädchen gegen das theokratische Regime
des Landes sie gehen auf die Straße
gegen die Repression der ayatollas gegen
den Brutalität der Sittenwächter für
ihre Freiheit und Menschenrechte
die Ermordung der Kurdin Gina Massa
Amini hat zu landesweiten Protesten
geführt die blutig niedergeschlagen
werden mindestens 76 Tote und über 1.500
Verhaftungen gibt es schon diese
Staatsgewalt verurteilen wir auf
Schärfste
wir bekommen nur einen Bruchteil der
Geschehnisse mit weil die Medien und das
Internet im Iran eingeschränkt bzw
gleichgeschaltet sind die gewaltexte
gegen friedliche Demonstrationen müssen
aber unverzüglich beendet werden jeder
einzelne Todesfall muss von dem Behörden
aufgeklärt werden dafür brauchen wir
eine unabhängige internationale
Untersuchungskommission eine un-
Menschenrechtskommission mit
zivilenvertreterinnen die diese ganzen
Fälle untersuchen müssen das fordern
auch die AktivistInnen und die
Zivilgesellschaft und die NGOs vor Ort
ich finde es gut dass in Deutschland und
in anderen Ländern viele Menschen auf
die Straße gehen um sich mit den mutigen
Frauen im Iran zu solidarisieren als
Bundestagsabgeordnete mit kurdischer
Migrationsgeschichte weiß sich wie
wichtig Solidarität in solchen Zeiten
sind die deutsche Realpolitik führt
unter der Ampelkoalition weiterhin einen
Kuschelkurs gegenüber Autokratien
gegenüber dem mulla-regime das Frauen
unterdrückt gegen nur Erdogan der
koordinnen mit chemischen Waffen
bekämpft gegenüber den Saudis die in
jenen jahrelang Zivilisten bombardiert
haben Erdogan möchte man als NATO
Verbündeten nicht verlieren außerdem
soll er ja die Flüchtlinge aus Europa
fernhalten
Saudi-Arabien ist wichtiger
Energielieferant und bei dem mularisimi
Meran fürchtet man eine Gefährdung der
Neuauflage des atomabkommens im Großen
und Ganzen geht das hier wieder um
Profite und geotrategische Interessen
aber so darf es nicht weitergehen
die mutigen Frauen im Iran brauchen
unsere Solidarität Frau berborg hat nach
ihrem amttritt eine feministische
hauspolitik angekündigt auch wenn sie
von Kriegsmüdigkeit inzwischen sprechen
in ihrer Außenpolitik wer wäre es jetzt
zeigt dass sie unter Beweis stellen wie
sie es auch wirklich mit den Feminismus
meinen handeln sie endlich
meine Damen und Herren die Repression
des Regimes in Teheran sind auf einem
Höhepunkt eines die International hat
recherchiert dass im ersten Jahr halb im
ersten Halbjahr 2022 im Iran mindestens
251 Menschen hingerichtet wurden oftmals
nach grob unfairen Gerichtsverfahren
tausende Menschen wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren strafrechtlich
verfolgt und willkürlich inhaftiert
deshalb brauchen wir Schutz und Aufnahme
für Menschen die vor dem Regime im Iran
fliehen
derzeit liegt die schutzquote bei den
Asylverfahren von Iranerinnen lediglich
bei 30 Prozent und stellen Sie sich mal
vor laut taz hatte die bayerische
Polizei in einem Fall einer Iranerin das
Kopftuch aufgezwungen um sie
ordnungsgemäß abschieben zu können
2017 meinte das Verwaltungsgericht
Nürnberg dass die Strafverfolgung im
Iran wegen Verstoßes gegen
Kleidervorschriften nicht asylrelevant
sei das habe keine politische Bedeutung
mich macht sowas einfach fassungslos
angesichts der Entwicklung im Iran
die geschlechtsspezifische Unterdrückung
von Frauen im Iran muss hier in
Deutschland als Asylgrund anerkannt
werden und es darf keine Abschiebungen
in den Iran geben
meine Damen und Herren die aktuellen
Proteste im Iran hatten in der Provinz
Kurdistan rochilat ihren Anfang und
haben sich im gesamten Land verbreitet
ich möchte auch noch mal daran erinnern
dass es die mutigen kurdischen
fraueneinheiten der jepudget sind die in
der gesamten Region für die Befreiung
der frauenkämpfen und große Opfer
bringen die Parole der kurdischen
Frauenbewegung shinjian Azadi übersetzt
Frauen Leben Freiheit hat weltweit an
Zuspruch gefunden unter diesem Slogan
liegen legen Frauen ihre Kopftücher ab
und schneiden sich aus Protest die Haare
weil sie zeigen wollen sie wollen leben
sie wollen ihn Freiheit und
selbstbestimmt leben ich bin beeindruckt
vom Kampf meiner Schwester im Iran und
den Kurdistan und möchte Ihnen meine
internationalistischen und
feministischen Grüße senden vielen Dank
ja und diesem Slogan den
noch mal genannt hat das kurdische was
sie auch auf ihrem T-Shirt vorne
aufgedruckt hatte ist kurdisch für
Frauen Leben Freiheit und das nutzen
auch die Demonstranten im Iran
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
hat dies
hat
letzte Woche eine Demonstration besucht
im teheran hat dies ist eine junge Frau
die auf die Demonstration gegangen ist
weil sie es nicht mehr ausgehalten hat
dass die Verhältnisse so sind wie sie
sind und weil sie protestieren wollte
gegen die Ermordung von Gina massamini
hat diesen hat auf dem Weg zu der
Demonstration noch eine Videobotschaft
hinterlassen für eine Freundin die sagt
ich bin nervös weil alle wissen was
denjenigen die protestieren blüht aber
die Sache ich bin froh dass ich dahin
gehe weil jetzt protestieren wir und
hoffentlich ändert sich darüber in ein
paar Jahren was in diesem Land und wir
können wieder atmen wenige Stunden
später ist sie tot sechs Kugeln hatte
sie in ihrem Körper sie wurde einfach
niedergeschossen
das was da passiert ist nicht neu dass
die Rechte der Frauen im Iran
unterdrückt werden ist uralt und seit 43
Jahren wird das auch noch staatlich
organisiert
dass Leute auf die Straße gehen und
protestieren ist nicht neu wir gehen auf
die Straße wegen der Unterdrückung der
Frau wegen Korruption wegen
Luftverschmutzung wegen fehlender Rechte
von Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern wegen
gefälschter Wahlen und die Antwort des
Regimes ist seit Jahrzehnten immer nur
dieselbe das ist die rohe Gewalt und das
ist der Grund warum jetzt die Leute auf
die Straße gehen gegen das gesamte Regie
neu ist auch nicht dass Frauen die
Proteste tragen neu ist dass sie sie
jetzt anführen und vor diesem
unglaublichen Mut dieser Frauen die vor
Sicherheitsleuten mit einer Knarre in
der Hand das Kopftuch ziehen und ihn ins
Gesicht schreien dass sie sich das nicht
mehr bieten lassen kann man nur auf die
Knie fallen
und es ist auch nicht neu dass wir in
diesem Hohen Hause uns leider mit diesem
mistständen im Iran beschäftigen müssen
wir haben letzte Legislaturperiode einen
Antrag initiiert als Grüne und ich bin
sehr dankbar gewesen dass wir bekommen
haben einen Zustimmung und einen
gemeinsamen Antrag der der großen
Koalition der FDP Union der Grünen und
der Menschenrechtsausschuss hat auch
diese Woche ein gemeinsamen Beschluss
gefasst einer sehr klaren Verurteilung
auch dafür ein riesen Dank haben leider
nicht alle zugestimmt ich weiß will
nicht wissen warum aber unbenommen davon
ist das natürlich unser aller Aufgabe
jetzt diesen Leuten diesen mutigen
Frauen beizustehen und was man jetzt im
Iran lernen kann ist nicht nur
inspirierend für alle die Demokratie
verteidigen weil die uns zeigen was
Freiheit und Demokratie Wert ist Kollege
hat völlig darauf zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen dass Leute die Unfreiheit
erlebt haben denn wissen was Freiheit
wert ist und ich kann nur hoffen dass
man nicht erst diese Erfahrung machen
muss um dieser Wertigkeit auch zu kennen
aber was wir gerade im Iran erleben ist
ja dass die Männer begreifen da wo
Frauenrechte unter die Räder kommen
kommen Menschenrechte aller unter die
Rede und deshalb gehen sie mit auf die
Straße und deshalb
und deshalb
bin ich so dankbar dass die
Außenministerin nicht nur sich dieser
Tage sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
und sich darum kümmert dass der Druck
erhöht wird ich bin nicht nur dankbar
dass die feministische Außenpolitik in
den Mittelpunkt ihrer Politik auch rückt
und bei jeder Reise ist das ein großes
Thema das ist ja glaube ich für alle die
sehen wollen noch sehr sichtbar ich bin
noch dankbar weil so viele Leute in
diesem Land das sehen sich davon
berühren lassen und das machen worum die
Frauen im Iran bitten nicht persönlich
geht ihr einigen so so hab so viele
Zuschriften bekommen so viele Posts
bekommen von Frauen nicht nur aber vor
allem von Frauen die sagen gerade jetzt
wo das Internet abgestellt wird sei
meine Stimme seit meine Stimme und wir
haben bei aller Notwendigkeit Druck zu
machen im politischen Raum bei aller
Notwendigkeit institutionell im
EU-Rahmen alles dafür zu tun damit auch
weitere Sanktionen beschlossen werden
wegen der Lage vor Ort haben auch die
Verpflichtung alles dafür zu tun damit
diese mutigen Frauen nicht vergessen
werden denn die internationale
Aufmerksamkeit
denn dieser internationale
Aufmerksamkeit die wir hier bringen die
wir aufbringen müssen ist sehr oft der
einzige Schutz denn dieser Frauen haben
und dieser ermutigt sie auch die gehen
natürlich aus purer Verzweiflung auf die
Straße ohne Angst weil sie diese Angst
verloren haben nach all den rückfliegen
der letzten Jahre aber sie wollen
natürlich auch gesehen werden weil sie
wissen dass sie nicht alleine sind und
dieses Gefühl müssen wir aufrecht halten
denn das ist ein Baustein vielleicht ein
kleiner aber der eine Baustein den wir
geben können damit das was hat Diesner
Jacky sich gewünscht hat am Ende des
Tages auch kommt nämlich Veränderungen
das Regime selbst ist zu Reformen schon
lange nicht mehr zwischen imstande das
ist Zeit dass die Bevölkerung das jetzt
macht und dafür sollten wir Ihnen
war das der Parteivorsitzende der Grünen
und als er hier auch noch mal sagte vor
dem Hut der Frauen kann man nur auf die
Knie fallen da gab es viel Applaus hier
im Haus nicht nur von den
ampelfraktionen auch beispielsweise von
Abgeordneten aus der CDU CSU-Fraktion
auch von Abgeordneten der Linksfraktion
also hier ein Signal was man auch senden
will in den Iran Dorothee Bär jetzt für
die Union
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer ich finde es
gut dass wir uns heute im Deutschen
Bundestag mit dem Thema beschäftigen
dass wir nicht nur so wie gestern
draußen bei den Demonstrationen bei den
Kundgebungen darüber sprechen sondern
eben auch hier im Deutschen Bundestag im
Parlament wo es hingehört dass wir hier
auch der Lage der iranischen Frauen
gedenken warum
weil wir gestern viele weil wir gestern
überparteilich erst beim deutschen
Frauenrat am Nachmittag auch bei Hawa
hält bei unterschiedlichen
Veranstaltungen waren und weil wir
einfach gespürt haben das was eben auch
schon angesprochen wurde dass wir auf
Demonstrationen haben gehen können dass
wir skandieren konnten dass wir die
Geschichten nacherzählen konnten und das
aber uns ein unterscheidet zu den Frauen
im Iran unsere Demonstrationen gestern
haben natürlich überhaupt keinen Mut
erfordert es ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit in unserem Land
auf die Straße zu gehen für uns alle es
ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit auch auf
diese Demonstrationen zu gehen so wie
wir sehen so wie wir gekleidet sein
wollen und deswegen möchte ich auch im
Namen unserer Fraktion noch mal wirklich
ganz ganz herzlich all den mutigen
Frauen danken und die Geschichten wurden
ja erzählt die eben wenn Sie auf eine
Demonstration gehen nicht wissen ob sie
abends wieder nach Hause kommen
und wir
wir wissen wir alle die wir heute hier
sind kennen die Geschichte von China
Massa Amini aber ich möchte trotzdem
noch mal plastisch vor Augen führen sie
war mit ihrem Bruder in Teheran zu
Besuch sie wurde am 13 September von der
sogenannten Sittenpolizei festgenommen
weil er hitschab ihr Kopftuch zu locker
gewesen sei man hätte ja Haare sehen
können das ist gerade für die jungen
Menschen vielleicht auf der Tribüne
unfassbar sich vorzustellen dass das ein
Grund ist jemanden zu Tode zu Foldern
wenigen Stunden später ist sie mit
schweren Kopfverletzungen ins Koma
gefallen im Polizeigewahrsam gestorben
mit 22 Jahren und wir schreiben das Jahr
wenn man sich mal überlegt wenn wir 43
Jahre zurückblicken dass das eine Zeit
wo vielleicht viele noch gar nicht die
hier jetzt im Bundestag sind auf der
Welt sind ins Jahr 1979 wurden New York
die ein Vollversammlung des
Übereinkommen zur Beseitigung jeder Form
von Diskriminierung der Frau
verabschiedet hat die sogenannte
frauenrechtskonvention wenn wir
überlegen dass natürlich der Iran keiner
der 186 Staaten ist die das ganze
ratifiziert haben wenn man überlegt dass
1979 auch eben dieses theokratische
System das Land beherrscht dann hoffe
ich dass wirklich der Tod von China
Massa ein Mini dazu beiträgt dass dieses
Regime endlich gebrochen werden kann
und es sind nicht nur die brutalsten
Handlungen der Unterdrückung die wir
jetzt sehen warum hat es ganze das jetzt
ausgelöst weil es gesehen wird weil es
Bilder gibt es ja nicht der erste Fall
und kein Einzelfall sondern die
iranische Justiz rechtfertigt für
freiheitliche Nationen auch
unvorstellbare Grollen es gibt
Hinrichtungen von Frauen es gibt
Steinigungen es gibt Ehrenmorde es gibt
Folter es gibt Missbrauch häusliche
Gewalt Kinderehen das gehört alles zum
Alltag im Iran das heißt
Frauenfeindlichkeit per Gesetz wir
Menschen kämpfen für die Freiheit für
ihre Rechte für die Rechte der Frauen
aber ehrlicherweise nicht nur für die
Rechte der Frauen auch für Menschen die
anders leben und für Menschen die anders
leben und die Frauen die auf die Straße
gehen ihre Kopftücher verbrennen sich
ihre Haare schneiden lassen die sind
gestern auch auf uns zugekommen und
haben gesagt für unsere Verwandten vor
Ort bitte seid ihr die Stimme
seid ihr die Bilder seid ihr das
Internet was wir momentan nicht haben
und sehr geehrte Frau
bundesaußenministerin
ich persönlich aber auch viele in meiner
Fraktion finden es sehr gut dass es auch
eine feministische Außenpolitik gibt und
ich finde schon dass die feministische
Außenpolitik auch jetzt natürlich der
Lackmustest ist gerade bei den Frauen im
Iran und mir hat es schon weh getan dass
gestern auch Schilder hochgehalten
wurden bei den Demonstrationen das sind
ja auch ihre UnterstützerInnen und und
Unterstützer die Fragen wo ist denn
jetzt die feministische Außenpolitik und
Ronja Ottmann hat in der FAZ in ihrem
Brief für China geschrieben und bei all
dem Gerät über feministische
Außenpolitik wo ist die feministische
Außenpolitik wenn man sie braucht mögen
den schönen wortentaten folgen und es
unterstreiche ich da haben sie uns auch
an ihrer Seite dass es eben dringend
auch Taten geben muss dass es
personenbezogenes Sanktionen gibt dass
den Sittenwächtern die im Iran kraft
Amtes morden und foltern dass sie sich
nicht mehr hier aufhalten können weil
sie nicht mehr von Jens datenbankkonten
zählen können dass es eine neue
iranische Strategie der Bundesregierung
gibt ich möchte mich da meinem Kollegen
der FDP anschließen und ich bin dankbar
und würde mich wirklich freuen wenn Ihre
Rede auch mit zum Maßstab der
Bundesregierung werden würde dass dieses
Dröhnen der Schweigen was wir zwei
Wochen gehört haben beendet wird dann
haben sie uns an ihrer Seite ganz
herzlichen Dank Dorothee Bär war das für
die CDU CSU-Fraktion die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun dr Nils
schwittersburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
Frau Leben Freiheit mit diesen rufen
sind viele tausend mutige Frauen auf der
Straße in vielen Städten des Irans sie
kämpfen gegen die strukturelle
Unterdrückung sie kämpfen für die
Freiheit und sie beweisen einmal mehr
und rufen uns allen auch in Deutschland
in Erinnerung
Frauenrechte sind Menschenrechte und
wenn Frauen für ihre Rechte auf die
Straße gehen kämpfen sie immer auch für
die Rechte und Freiheitsrechte der
Männer nicht nur der Erfahrung sie
kämpfen für die Freiheit der
Gesellschaft für Bürgerinnen und
Bürgerrechte und deshalb ist der Zustand
der Frauenrechte immer auch der Maßstab
für den Zustand der Menschenrechte in
einer jeden Gesellschaft und in allen
lebensstaatswesen und deshalb müssen wir
leider festhalten dass der Iran
trotz aller Bemühungen Frauen
beispielsweise in Bildung und Ausbildung
nach vorne zu bringen dass der Iran die
Islamische Republik Iran strukturellen
Frauen strukturell frauenfeindlich und
damit auch strukturell
menschenrechtsfeindlich ist und deshalb
ist es auch so richtig dass die
feministische Außenpolitik so wie die
Außenministerin sie formuliert hat an
die Strukturen geht im Iran in anderen
Staaten und Gesellschaften dieser Welt
und deshalb kann ich den Vorwurf Frau
Bär auch nicht nachvollziehen es würde
ein grünes Schweigen gehen aus der
Bundesregierung sowohl der Kanzler wie
die Außenministerin haben sich klar auf
die Seite der Frauen im Iran geschlagen
und wir unterstützen Sie uneingeschränkt
[Applaus]
auf Kurdisch lautet der Ruf Jin Gian
asadi Frau Akbulut hat die
Freundlichkeit gab es sogar aufs T-Shirt
zu schreiben und hier zu präsentieren
damit ist aber auch eins angezeigt durch
diese Formulierung
der Iran ist ein vielfilterstaat und
trotz der zur Schau gestellten Toleranz
wie sie uns über regierungsmedien immer
wieder präsentiert wird
ist auch die Unterdrückung von
kulturellen rechten von sozialen rechten
Programm in der Islamischen Republik und
diese strukturelle Unterdrückung von
Vielfalt spielt eben rein in ein
strukturell freiheitsfeindliches Regime
und es ist ein Grund mehr die Freiheit
und Demokratie Bewegung im Iran voll zu
unterstützen
was heißt jetzt Unterstützung natürlich
heißt es und es sollten wir nicht gering
achten Solidarität Solidarität die wir
zum Ausdruck bringen durch die Debatte
hier im Parlament parteiübergreifen die
wir zum Ausdruck bringen in Äußerungen
bei demonstrierte Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die gasumlage ist ja gekippt
die gaspreisbremse kommt die
Bundesregierung will ein 200 Milliarden
Abwehrschirm gegen die
energiepreisbremse gegen die
Energiekrise wir hören jetzt mal den
Fraktionschef der Union jetzt plant
einen umfassenden Abwehrschirm wie sie
es nennt
zugunsten der Unternehmen der privaten
Haushalte in Deutschland gegen zu hohe
Gaspreise und zu hohe Strompreise
aufzuspannen wir sehen in der
Beschlussfassung der Bundesregierung
einige Formulierungen wieder die uns
bekannt vorkommen weil wir sie auch
schon vorher verwendet haben sie
erinnern sich daran dass wir das Wort
Schutzschirm verwendet haben
insbesondere für die Gas importierenden
Unternehmen sie erinnern sich daran dass
wir auch das Wort Preisbremse schon
einmal verwende haben in den Beschlüssen
von Murnau als wir mit dem
geschäftsführenden Fraktionsvorstand
dort zum Ende der Sommerpause getagt
haben
die Zahl 200 Milliarden Euro überrascht
uns einigermaßen weil wir auch in den
Beschlüssen der Bundesregierung nicht
nachvollziehen können auf welcher
Kalkulationsgrundlage eigentlich diese
Zahl ermittelt worden ist es scheint nur
so viel klar zu sein dass jetzt 30
Milliarden gasumlage durch 200
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden ersetzt
werden ich will einmal kurze den Blick
auf die Gesamtverschuldung werfen die
die Bundesregierung damit in diesem Jahr
auftürmt wir sind jetzt bei 60
Milliarden Energie- und Klimafonds 100
Milliarden Bundeswehr und 200 Milliarden
WSF also
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der
befüllt werden soll damit sind wir bei
ungefähr 360 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden allein in diesem Jahr das ist
fast so viel wie ein ganzer
Bundeshaushalt der jetzt den
Schattenhaushalten der Bundesregierung
aufgetürmt wird so weit so gut oder
schlecht die entscheidende Frage ist
wofür wird das Geld eigentlich verwendet
es kommen die Worte gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse in dem Papier vor
beide mal bleibt völlig offen wie diese
gaspreisbremse und die strompreisbremse
denn gestaltet werden sollen das sind
ziemlich komplexe Vorhaben wir gehen
davon aus dass mit diesen 200 Milliarden
Euro jetzt nicht das letzte Wort
gesprochen ist sondern das erste Wort am
Beginn eines
gesetzgebungsmarathons den wir jetzt in
den nächsten Tagen Wochen möglicherweise
Monaten hier in Berlin erleben und sie
werden es verstehen dass wir
einigermaßen skeptisch sind was dann
dabei herauskommt nachdem wir in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten eine Vielzahl
von schweren handwerklichen Fehlern in
der Gesetzgebungsarbeit der
Bundesregierung gesehen haben wir werden
es jetzt begleiten konstruktiv begleiten
sowie der Bundeskanzler das völlig zu
Recht aus seiner Sicht auch gesagt hat
wir behalten uns allerdings auch
Zustimmung oder Ablehnung vor bevor wir
nicht die konkreten gesetzgebungstexte
der Bundesregierung sehen ich will
abschließend hinzufügen wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass die Bundesregierung auch
in ihren Beschlüssen sozusagen mal vor
der Klammer aller Details darauf
hingewiesen hätte dass das Angebot an
verfügbarer Energie in Deutschland jetzt
deutlich und drastisch erhöht werden
muss und das auch das die Nachfrage
deutlich und drastisch gesenkt werden
muss das haben die Ministerpräsidenten
gestern in ihrem Beschluss so noch
einmal zum Ausdruck gebracht im
Beschluss der Bundesregierung bleibt das
heute unerwähnt ich gehe davon aus dass
die Bundesregierung das tut dass die
versucht so viel Angebot wie möglich zu
beschaffen und die Nachfrage so stark
wie möglich zu dämpfen allerdings schon
die Beschlüsse zur Kernenergie dass die
Bundesregierung hier eben nicht bis zu
Ende geht sondern auf halber Strecke
stehen bleibt bei diesem Thema gilt
übrigens auch für die Kohlekraftwerke
von denen bis jetzt nur zwei am Netz
sind zugesagt waren acht Gigawatt am
Netz sind zwei Gigawatt also wir liegen
auch bei dem Angebot weit hinter den
Möglichkeiten und auch hinter den
Notwendigkeiten zurück insofern müssen
diese 200 Milliarden Euro jetzt eine
Lücke schließen die schwierig sein wird
geschlossen zu werden aber noch einmal
wir begrüßen dass die Bundesregierung
jetzt endlich zu Entscheidungen kommt
was im der Teil daraus wird werden wir
sehen wir gehen jedenfalls von einem
ziemlich langen relativ komplizierten
Gesetzgebungsprozess aus der uns in den
nächsten Wochen hier noch beschäftigen
wird vielen Dank
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nach
Wochen und Jahr gar Monaten eines
gezerrres in der Ampel innerhalb der
Ampel um die gasumlage scheint dieses
Wirrwar das vom Bundesminister Habeck
angerichtet worden ist zumindest an
dieser Stelle ein vorläufiges Ende zu
nehmen ob damit wieder Sicherheit
entsteht ist vollkommen offen weil
dieses wirr war um die gasumlage jetzt
ersetzt wird durch eine Überschrift der
großen Zahlen 200 Milliarden Euro bei
denen nicht klar ist wie sich diese Zahl
zusammensetzt und nicht klar ist wie
diese Bundesregierung diese Zahl
hergeleitet hat das wird wohl nicht
ausreichen um Sicherheit und Vertrauen
zu schaffen hier durch diese Krise
kommen sondern es geht vor allem darum
wie dieses Geld auch seine Verwendung
findet um Bürgen Bürger um die
Mittelstand um die Unternehmen gegenüber
den teuren Energiepreisen auch zu
schützen deswegen sehe ich an dieser
Stelle bei den Entscheidungen überhaupt
keinen doppelwumms sondern diese
Entscheidung hinterlässt doppelte
Fragezeichen
die Bundesregierung ist aufgefordert zu
klären wie diese
gaspreisbremse die wir befürworten sogar
seit Monaten ja eingefordert haben auch
funktionieren soll nach ihrer
Einschätzung wir haben dazu Vorschläge
gemacht sowohl was den Großhandelspreis
anbelangt als auch was die Entlastung
der Haushalte direkt mit einem
bürgerbasispreis anbelangt der
Schutzschirm vom Grundsatz ist zu
begrüßen die Ausgestaltung hier ist
vollkommen betroffen von daher gibt es
eine erhebliche Arbeit zu tun von Seiten
der ampelregierung um eben Sicherheit
und Vertrauen herzustellen was
vollkommen offen ist auch und deswegen
doppelte Fragezeichen ist wie die
Angebotsseite das heißt die
kapazitätszeit im Energiemarkt
zusätzlich gestärkt werden soll nach wie
vor vollkommen unzureichend gelöst ist
die Frage der Kernenergie es ist nicht
ausreichend dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister erklärt er
könnte sich das Weiterlaufen von zwei
Kraftwerken über drei Monate vorstellen
die unterschiedlichen Einschätzungen der
Streit in der Ampel ist noch mal
deutlich geworden ganz offensichtlich
sieht der Bundesfinanzminister die
Situation anders als der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister wir haben
einen Antrag eine Gesetzesantrag im
Deutschen Bundestag gestellt und das
Atomgesetz zu ändern und die drei
Kraftwerke weiter laufen zu lassen bis
ins Jahr 2024 die Angebotsseite ist
deswegen so entscheidend das heißt die
Energiekapazität ist deswegen so
entscheidend weil durch mehr Kapazität
im Markt werden mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Methoden die
Preise gesenkt je mehr
marktwirtschaftliche Methoden die Preise
senken umso weniger staatliche Mittel
aus dem vor benötigen wir und deswegen
ist es nicht alleine damit getan 200
Milliarden auszuloben man muss auch über
die klare
Mittelverwendung reden und das heißt wir
brauchen mehr Energie im Markt um diese
Mittelverwendung möglichst sparsam zu
gestalten
dann kommen wir noch zu drei Fragen Frau
Maurer vom ZDF
[Musik]
überrascht was ist dazwischen passiert
dazwischen ist gar nichts passiert der
Bundeskanzler hat das in seiner
Pressekonferenz heute bekannt gegeben es
hat darüber mit uns keine Gespräche
gegeben worüber ich mich nicht beklage
das ist dann Entscheidung des
Bundeskanzlers ich nehme sie so zur
Kenntnis ich gehe jedenfalls bisher
davon aus dass anders als beim
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr der
Bundeskanzler uns bei diesem
Sondervermögen nicht braucht im
Parlament weil dieses Sondervermögen
nach dem was wir jetzt gerade auch in
der Unterrichtung durch den
Bundeskanzler gehört haben so aufgebaut
werden soll dass von der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes eine Ausnahme gemacht
wird wegen einer unabweisbaren Notlage
und diese Feststellung einer solchen
Notlage kann mit der Kanzlermehrheit im
Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen werden
und dazu braucht die Bundesregierung die
anderen Fraktionen des Deutschen
Bundestages nicht also Sie haben recht
es ist ein völlig anderes politisches
vorgehen
wir sind über die das Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr
frühzeitig
einigermaßen informiert worden hier hat
es eine Information über die Presse
gegeben ja Frau Schwizer von der ARD
bitte
also die Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse
steht ja seit längerer Zeit im Raum wenn
die Bundesregierung
unseren Vorschlägen gefolgt wäre auch
Geld einzusparen dann wäre es nach
unserer Einschätzung jedenfalls in
diesem Umfang nicht notwendig gewesen
die Frage wie eine solche
gaspreisdeckelung
vorgenommen werden kann ist sehr sehr
komplex Gas wird weltweit gehandelt wir
haben ja den Vorschlag gemacht dass auf
der Ebene der Großhandelspreise zu
decken aus unserer Sicht muss das
europaweit geschehen das kann man
national wahrscheinlich nicht machen und
selbst wenn man es europaweit macht
besteht die große Gefahr dass im
Gashandel arbitratische Geschäfte
gemacht werden zugunsten anderer Händler
und so Lasten des deutschen
Steuerzahlers ohne dass am Ende des
Tages beim Verbraucher in Deutschland
etwas ankommt ich habe die
Bundesregierung auf diese Gefahr bereits
hingewiesen und ich gehe davon aus dass
sie das auch berücksichtigt wir müssen
sehr aufpassen dass dieses Geld an der
richtigen ankommt wenn es denn in diesem
Umfang ausgegeben wird
dann die letzte Frage von Herrn gattmann
vom Spiegel
dass die Koalition diesmal die
Zustimmung der Union nicht braucht bei
den Sondervermögen habe ich sie aber
richtig verstanden dass sie dennoch
sagen sie behalten sich als Union vor am
Ende doch zuzustimmen also ich bin
jedenfalls zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht
auf Ablehnung festgelegt sondern wir
schauen uns das jetzt an was die
Koalition dort tut und es kommt jetzt
auf die Details an und das sage ich
jetzt hier nicht nur sag mal politische
rhetorisch sondern es kommt jetzt
wirklich darauf an wie das ausgestaltet
wird und ich will das noch mal sagen das
sind hochkomplexe Vorgänge das sind
Markteingriffe durch den Staat oder
durch die Europäische Kommission je
nachdem wir das an sich zieht und das
ist bei Gas und Strom sehr
unterschiedlich bei Strom steht ja immer
noch im Raum die Abschöpfung dieser
sogenannten übergewinne völlig offen wie
das funktioniert und ob man das
überhaupt verfassungsrechtlich absichern
kann beim Gas habe ich auf den
weltweiten Sachverhalt hingewiesen also
wir werden mal sehen was jetzt kommt
also diese 200 Milliarden sind sozusagen
in den Raum gestellt eine Summe die man
ausgeben kann ohne dass die
Bundesregierung klargestellt hat wie das
denn im Detail gehen soll das hätte man
vielleicht etwas früher mal anpacken
können also wenn wir es zu tun gehabt
hätten wir hätten eine andere
Reihenfolge gewählt wir hätten erst die
Instrumente festgelegt und dann das
Preisschild dann gehängt wir haben jetzt
einen Preisschild ohne Instrument wir
wissen nicht welches Instrument mit 200
Milliarden Euro angeschafft werden soll
und insofern ist es auch völlig offen
heute zu sagen ja oder nein
wir sind gespannt wir haben durchaus
festgestellt dass in der Pressekonferenz
der ampelregierung darauf hingewiesen
worden ist dass die Vorschläge oder
Vorschläge der Unionsfraktion übernommen
worden sind allerdings sehen wir die
Ausgestaltung dieser Vorschläge im
Papier so nicht konkretisiert das heißt
es wird darauf ankommen was die Ampel
auch dann im Detail über die Frage
gaspreisbremse und andere Elemente mit
uns dann zu diskutieren hat falls Sie
bereit ist darüber überhaupt zu
diskutieren bisher und das kann man an
der Stelle sagen das war durchaus
befremdlich haben wir eine Information
erhalten die nach der Pressekonferenz
stattgefunden hat wir nehmen das zur
Kenntnis aber das zeigt unbedingt noch
nicht dass man auf die Unionsfraktion an
der Stelle zugehen will
okay vielen dank danke schön
waren also die Statements von Friedrich
Merz und Alexander Dobrindt hier zum
gaspreisdeckel der Ampel im
Reichstagsgebäude allerdings ein paar
Stockwerke über dem Plenarsaal jetzt
sind wir wieder im Plenarsaal und dort
ist noch die Aktuelle Stunde die die
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
die FDP hier verlangt haben es geht um
die Proteste im Iran nachdem die
22-Jährige Mascha armini in Polizei
Gewahrsam gestorben ist ja am 13
September es ist noch unklar woran sie
gestorben ist allerdings wurde sie
festgenommen weil sie anscheinend so ist
der Vorwurf ihr Kopftuch nicht richtig
getragen hat
und
deswegen wurde sie wie auch andere
festgenommen und brach dann in der
Festnahme unter eben ungeklärten
Umständen zusammen drei Tage später ist
sie dann im Krankenhaus gestorben und
seitdem gibt es jeden Tag Proteste im
Iran dagegen geht die sogenannte nun
muss man das wirklich in
Anführungszeichen sagen
Sicherheitskräfte die gehen dagegen
gewaltsam vor das Internet ist gestört
und es wird hier versucht deutlich zu
unterbinden dass die Menschen sich
dagegen aussprechen und mindestens 76
Menschen wurden schon getötet so sagt es
die nicht Regierungsorganisation Iran
Human Rights die in Oslo sitzt darunter
sollen auch Frauen und Kinder sein und
wie Deutschland reagieren kann wie
Deutschland reagieren sollte das ist
hier in Bundestag jetzt in der
wenn sich die Grünen Debatte die Frage
und Lamia Cador spricht dafür jetzt für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
auf den Tribünen da oben ich bin mir
eigentlich nicht wirklich sicher ob wir
heute aus dieser aus diesem sicheren
Land und dieser sicheren Stelle in
dieser sicheren Herzkammer unserer
Demokratie wirklich nachempfinden können
was uns die Bilder aus dem Iran zeigen
und ich bin auch nicht sicher ob auch
ich mir wirklich vorstellen kann wie es
sich anfühlt wegen eines verrutschten
Kopftuchs festgenommen zu werden oder
wenn meine Tochter nach einem
Spaziergang mit ihren Freundinnen im
Park nicht nach Hause kommen würde und
dann stellte sich heraus dass ihr
T-Shirt verrutscht war sondern ein Stück
ihres Rückens sichtbar wurde und eine
sogenannte Religionspolizei die ja
übrigens auch von Frauen also in denen
auch Frauen offensichtlich der auf
Frauen tätig sind sie deshalb in
Gewahrsam festhält das ist natürlich
unvorstellbar welche Ängste Kämpfe
Hoffnungen Erschütterungen die iranische
Frauen dieser Tage durchstehen auch ich
vermag es nur zu erahnen
trotzdem rufe ich Ihnen zu wir sehen was
hier aushaltet wir sehen wie ihr leidet
und wir sind an eurer Seite
für schlagen für schlagen Knüppeln
anbrüllen foltern und erschießen gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung nirgends niemals
egal von wem und mit welcher Begründung
daher fährt urteile ich von dieser
Stelle des Hohen Hauses dem Deutschen
Bundestag das Vorgehen des iranischen
Regimes auf schärfste ich prangere seine
Menschenrechtsverletzungen an und rufe
Ihnen zu hören sie auf Frauen
anzugreifen hören sie auf ihnen das
Leben zur Hölle zu machen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Schicksal der Frauen und Mädchen rührt
uns besonders an aber es geht noch um
viel mehr noch Jahrzehnten der
Unterdrückung da müssen Wirtschaft der
Korruption durch das Regime mitterern
ist dieser Tage erneut er sichtlich wie
groß der Widerstand in der iranischen
Gesellschaft insgesamt ist wenn nicht
auf Linie des Regimes ist ist dagegen so
einfach stellt sich das im Moment da
nach der gewaltsamen Niederschlagung der
Proteste von 2019 setzen die Iraner und
Iraner erneut ihr Leben aufspielen in
dieser Stunde geht es für uns einerseits
darum sich mit den Menschen die im Iran
seit dem Tod der jungen Kurden Gina
massamini vor elf Tagen auf die Straße
gehen zu solidarisieren und andererseits
dem regimeteran eine eindeutige
Nachricht zukommen zu lassen nämlich die
Gewalt gegenüber Demonstranten und
Demonstranten wird Konsequenzen haben
deshalb hat unsere Außenministerin auch
jetzt gerade sehr deutlich gesagt und
gemacht den iranischen Botschafter ins
Auswärtige Amt bestellt und arbeite mit
Hochdruck an weiteren gemeinsamen
EU-Sanktionen Briefe wie der von der
Frauenunion der CDU der die Ministerin
zum Handeln aufruft sind daher doch
befremdlich denn im Grunde genommen hat
sie all das gemacht was sie gerade von
ihr verlangt haben
richtig die Außenministerin sagte und
ich zitiere sie noch mal wiederholen Sie
hiermit auch die Proteste im Iran zeigen
einmal mehr warum eine feministische
Außenpolitik den Unterschied macht denn
wenn Frauen wie Gina Massa Amini wegen
unmoralischer Kleidung nicht sicher sind
dann ist keiner in der Gesellschaft
sicher und genauso ist es so behält es
sich leider leider seit Jahrzehnten im
Iran es herrscht Willkür die selbst
ernannten Sittenwächter wollen
entscheiden was islamisch und nicht
islamisch ist Berichte von
Gewaltanwendungen und Folter an
Gewahrsam der angeblichen Sittenpolizei
sind die Regeln nicht die Ausnahme dass
Gina Massa Amini mutmaßlich wegen der
Verhaftung durch diese Leute verstarb
überrascht niemanden es zeigt einmal
mehr das Gewalt zu Kontrolle von
Menschen oder der Menschen für die
Anhänger des müller-regimes ein
legitimes Mittel ist ihr eigenes Ziel
eigene Macht und Privilegien erhalten
und so geht es den Demonstranten und
DemonstrantInnen eben nicht primär um
den Kopftuchzwang im Iran wie manche
hier behaupten sondern die Proteste
wenden sich viel mehr gegen eine brutale
Herrschaft die zudem das Land isoliert
und durch Korruption und Kriege
heruntergewirtschaftet hat sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir können die Proteste nicht
diskutieren ohne die destabilisierende
Wirkung und Rolle des Irans in der
Region zu erwähnen im Irak im Libanon in
Syrien im Jemen unterstützt Teheran
direkt oder indirekt gewaltbereiter
Akteure sie bedrohen die Sicherheit
Israels und anderer Staaten in dieser
Region die russische Armee hat zuletzt
wenn mehr Drohnen iranischer Produktion
in der Ukraine eingesetzt auch das zeigt
deutlich dass das iranische Regime
dass das Regime noch mal dass das
iranische Regime auf Seiten des
aggresshaus steht gemeinsam mit unseren
internationalen Partnern müssen wir
jetzt handeln und das aggressive
Verhalten der Mullahs führt dazu dass
wir unsere Anstrengung weiter verstärken
sollten ich möchte meine heutige rede
mit einem Zitat von gilt das sahibi
beenden sie ist Ärztin
Politikwissenschaftlerin Journalistin
und deutsche mit iranischen Wurzeln sie
stellt fest eine der weltweit größten
feministischen Protestbewegung der
vergangenen Jahrzehnte geht vom Nahen
Osten aus Isen that something darauf
kann ich nur entgegnen und deshalb
verdienen diese Frauen unsere größte
Anerkennung und Solidarität vielen Dank
[Applaus]
appelliert hier an die Abgeordneten das
es Anerkennung und Respekt doch braucht
kriegt ihr auch noch mal eine Umarmung
von omidori PUR der hier auch schon
gesprochen hat Frank Schwabe ist der
letzte Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe der SPD-Fraktion frau
Präsidentin verehrte Damen und Herren
Herr Dr Röttgen ich weiß gar nicht ob
ihnen das aufgefallen ist sie haben ja
versucht hier irgendwie ein Popanz zu
konstruieren eine Theorie aufzustellen
die sie sozusagen sich ausgedacht haben
und selbst versucht haben hier zu
belegen als sie dann über das
nuklearabkommen gesprochen haben dachte
ich jetzt kommt er irgendwie ein
Vorschlag jetzt sagen Sie am Ende das
wir wollen Sie vielleicht auch gar nicht
mehr haben was haben sie wollen ja schon
wirklich beides haben und sie haben dann
gesagt wir tun aber die Außenministerin
und wir alle tun zu wenig im Bereich der
Menschenrechtspolitik gegenüber dem Iran
aber ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen
aufgefallen ist mir ist jedenfalls
aufgefallen Sie haben mir überhaupt
nicht keinen Vorschlag dazu gemacht zu
was sie eigentlich diese Bundesregierung
auffordern sondern sie haben einen
Popanz aufgebaut und ich finde das kann
nicht funktionieren weil dieser Teil des
Hauses diese Koalition beides tut die
bemüht sich um den Weltfrieden und sie
stellt aber auch die Menschenrechte in
den Mittelpunkt ihrer Außenpolitik und
das ist auch richtig so
wir gedenken heute
Gina Masa armini 22 Jahre alte
Iranerinnen und mit ihr vielen anderen
tausenden bei Protesten getöteten
Hingerichteten den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten was ist das eigentlich für
eine Regierung eines Staates die die
eigene Bevölkerung wegen einer
Kleiderordnung verhaften verprügeln und
mutmaßlich auch
totschlagen lässt weltweit und auch hier
in Deutschland erinnern wir und
unterstützen wir diese Proteste die
deutsche Bevölkerung aber
interessanterweise haben wir viele
Menschen die aus dem Iran zu uns
gekommen sind hier auch in der deutschen
Politik der Parteivorsitzende der Grünen
der Generalsekretär der FDP wir haben
einen fraktionsreferenten aus den
menschenrechtsbereich Arash sakori
und die sind ja wahrscheinlich nicht
deswegen hier weil es so toll in
Deutschland ist hier ist es auch toll
sondern das sind deswegen hier weil sie
eben nicht mehr im Iran leben konnten
und deswegen ist es kein vom Besten
gesteuerter
Protest oder keine vom Westen gesteuerte
Revolution aber es immer da kommt
sondern es ist ein Protest und der
Unterstützung eines Prozesses von einem
freien Teil der Welt da wo Iranerinnen
und Iraner ihr ihre Heimat gefunden
haben weil wir hier eben offen reden
können weil wir hier für Freiheit und
für Offenheit in der Gesellschaft stehen
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir das
hier gemeinsam alle diskutieren können
und dass wir in der Tat gemeinsam und
das sollten wir auch nicht untergraben
als Deutscher Bundestag ein klares
Signal richten wir sind an der Seite der
Iranerinnen und Iraner die dort jetzt
protestieren
und ich will erinnern an nach zagavi und
andere die in Deutschland eigentlich
leben und beheimatet sind die aber ab
und zu im Iran sind und jetzt verhaftet
sind Neid targary seit dem 16 Oktober
des Jahres 2020 und ich will auch daran
erinnern dass iranische
Regierung von Iran geschickte
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter hier in
Deutschland nicht nur im Iran auch in
Deutschland ihr Unwesen treiben und
Menschen die hier in der Opposition sind
im Exil sind bedrängen und ich finde
dass wir alle gemeinsam auch noch mal
genauer hingucken sollten zusammen mit
den deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden ob das
eigentlich so sein kann ob wir da nicht
weiter tätig werden können
seit jetzt mittlerweile 13 Tagen eben
die Proteste nicht ab und es gibt ja
unterschiedliche Einschätzungen dazu
wie lange das geht und wie das wie das
ausgeht nach all den Erfahrungen der
letzten Jahre mein Eindruck ist
jedenfalls und das was ich geschildert
bekomme das ist so ist das anders als
2016 und 2019 jetzt alle Schichten dabei
sind
Vertreterinnen Vertreter Menschen aus
großen und kleinen Städten traditionelle
und liberale Communities und eben auch
Menschen die wir als vermutlich
unpolitisch beschreiben würden und
deswegen will ich auch an der Stelle
danken sada asmun und der iranischen
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft und ich finde
gerade bei der Debatte die wir rund um
Katar führen Stände ist der FIFA gut an
sich klar zur positionieren und sich mit
dieser iranischen
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer zur
solidarisieren
die Angst ist bei vielen der Mut
gewichen zum Teil der Mut der
Verzweiflung die trotz aller Erfahrungen
der brutalen Niederschlagung und 1500
Toten
an drei Tagen 2019 jetzt auf die Straße
gehen Frauen das ist vielfach betont
worden sind die Speerspitze dieses
Protestes unter der Parole San sengeti
asadi Frau Leben und Freiheit und
deswegen ist das vielleicht ein
positiver Nebeneffekt der heutigen
Debatte hier habe das ja jetzt
verstanden dass zumindest Teile der
Unionsfraktion das Thema einer
feministischen Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik jetzt ganz gut
finden weil es genau darum ja geht
Menschen auf der Welt die unterdrückt
sind aus unterschiedlichen Gründen die
unterdrückt sind aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen instand zu versetzen für ihre
Freiheit und für ihr Leben und für ihr
freies Leben sich entsprechend
einzusetzen und dass wir das mit aller
Kraft aus Deutschland entsprechend
unterstützen
und ist alles Ablauf an letzter Satz ein
letzter Satz es ist ja hier von Religion
geredet worden ich finde das muss man
sich auch noch mal klar machen es ist
keine freifrage von Religion Menschen
vorzugeben wie sie zu leben haben es
gibt andere muslimische Länder wo wir ja
solche Vorschriften nicht haben deswegen
kann das schon nicht richtig sein und
ich finde das ist das was man sowohl den
Mullahs im Iran sagen muss aber auch der
AFD dass das keine Frage von Religion
ist wenn Menschen wenn Frauen frei leben
wollen vielen herzlichen Dank
Frank Schwabe war das der letzte Redner
hier in dieser aktuellen Stunde zu den
Protesten nach dem Tod von Mason Amini
etwas gesagt danke all denen die mir
geholfen haben dass ich gerade in dieser
Debatte nicht in Redebeiträge
hineingehen musste um die Redezeit
entsprechend einzuklagen ich Spalte mir
noch vor sowohl verbale Äußerungen in
der Debatte als auch nonverbale
Demonstrationen und Äußerungen im
Protokoll im Video und anderswo zu
prüfen und gegebenenfalls die Dinge die
zu sanktionieren sind zu sanktionieren
aber hiermit ist erst einmal die
Aktuelle Stunde beendet
die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Pau
hat hier noch einmal deutlich gemacht
wir es müssen wir noch klären auf was
sie sich dort bezieht bzw vielleicht
wird sie das auch selber machen noch
kaufe der nächsten Debatte da geht es
wieder um deutsche Politik inländische
Politik es geht um das Kurzarbeitergeld
das wurde nun schon
wiederholt
erleichter zugänglich gemacht und die
ampelfraktionen wollen hier mit einem
Gesetzentwurf dafür sorgen dass es auch
bis Mitte kommenden Jahres ein
vereinfachten Zugang zum Kurzarbeiter
Geld gibt und das ist dort auch
Vereinfachungen gibt zum Beispiel was
die Prüfung der Voraussetzungen
angeht natürlich hat dort die aktuelle
Lage dafür den
ist die aktuelle Lage dafür zuständig
einerseits der Ukraine Krieg und auch
natürlich die Ungewissheit wie es in der
corona-pandemie weitergeht und deswegen
wurde hier eingesetzt Entwurf vorgelegt
über den nach ca 40 Minuten auch
abgestimmt werden soll und der
zuständige Minister Hubertus Heil
spricht als erstes dazu frau Präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
demokratischen Parteien in diesem Haus
sich einig Putin darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen wieder in der Ukraine noch bei
dem Versuch mit dem Einsatz von Gas als
Waffe unsere westlichen Gesellschaften
wirtschaftlich und sozial zu
destabilisieren denn sein Ziel ist es
erklärtermaßen mit dem Einsatz von Gas
als Waffe wirtschaftlich und soziale
Unruhen herbeizuführen die unsere
Solidarität mit der Ukraine brüchig
machen sollen das werden wir nicht
zulassen wir werden uns nicht spalten
lassen meine Damen und
und deshalb sind es fünf Dinge die sich
die Bundesregierung vorgenommen hat um
Deutschland in dieser wirtschaftlichen
sozialen herausfordernden Zeit gut und
sicher durch diese Zeit zu führen
erstens die Sicherung der
Versorgungssicherheit die Anstrengung
dieser Bundesregierung vor allen Dingen
des Bundeskanzlers und meines Kollegen
Robert Habeck seit Beginn dieser
Regierung sind darauf ausgerichtet eben
dafür zu sorgen dass wir durch diesen
Winter kommen und genug Gas zur
Verfügung ist dass wir weder in die Gas
Notlage 4 kommen noch rationieren müssen
und das scheint zu gelingen zweitens
durch Eingriffe in den Markt in den
Strom und Gasmarkt mit den heute
beschlossenen Maßnahmen mit dem
Abwehrschirm gegen diesen Angriffskrieg
was die wirtschaftlichen Folgen betrifft
werden wir dafür sorgen dass für
Wirtschaft und Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher Gas und Strompreise in einem
erträglichen Maß gehalten werden
drittens mit dem Entlastungspaket den
Leistungspaketen von insgesamt 100
Milliarden Euro sorgen wir für gezielte
Entlastung von Menschen mit unteren und
mittleren Einkommen und viertens meine
Damen und Herren heute ist auch
beschlossen worden dass wir
Wirtschaftshilfen ausweiten werden um
vor allen Dingen kleine
mittelständischen Unternehmen die durch
gestiegene Produktionskosten in
Schieflage gekommen sind oder bei denen
die Nachfrage wegbricht zu helfen und
fünftens meine Damen und Herren damit
bin ich bei dem Gesetzentwurf heute
unser Ziel ist und bleibt es dass wir
auch den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt die
deutschen Arbeitsplätze stabil und
robust durch diese Krise führen und
deshalb
habe ich entschieden als
Bundesarbeitsminister dass wir die
Verordnungsermächtigung der Deutschen
Bundestag uns noch bis 30 September
gegeben hat nutzen und den vereinfachten
zu
Kurzarbeit auch in diesem Winter
gewährleisten um Sicherheit zu geben für
die Unternehmen die in Schlagseite
kommen für die Beschäftigten die sich
Angst machen um ihre Arbeitsplätze wir
haben gestern im Kabinett zusätzlich
entschieden dass wir auch
arbeitnehmerüberlassungs heißt
Leiharbeit abschirmen werden weil wir
Anzeichen haben dass da Menschen
entlassen werden können wenn wir sie
heute mit diesem Gesetz darum bitten als
Deutscher Bundestag in diesem Winter der
Bundesregierung alle
Verordnungsermächtigung bis zur Mitte
nächsten Jahres in die Hand zu geben
dann dann
damit wir Vorsorge treffen für
wirtschaftliche Eskalation ich hoffe
dass sie nicht von allen diesen
verordnungsermächtigen Gebrauch machen
werden aber klar ist meine Damen und
Herren Kurzarbeit hat in der
corona-pandemie dafür gesorgt dass wir
Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen sichern
konnten es hat geholfen dass Unternehmen
Fachkräfte an Bord halten könnten um
wieder durchzustatten es hat die
gesamtwirtschaftliche Nachfrage
stabilisiert und deshalb ist ganz klar
in Krisenzeiten gilt es Brücke zu bauen
und Sicherheit zu schaffen meine Bitte
ist diesem Hause gegenüber diesem
Gesetzentwurf zuzustimmen um Sicherheit
am Arbeitsmarkt zu schaffen putin wird
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen wie der
wirtschaftlich noch sozial noch
militärisch uns gegenüber meine Damen
und Herren und deshalb bitte ich Sie um
die wirtschaftlichen Unterstützung wie
notwendig sind dankeschön
der Bundesminister für Arbeit und
Soziales Hubertus Heil hat hier für den
Gesetzentwurf geworben über den auch
dann die Abgeordneten abstimmen jetzt
gehen wir aber erst einmal in die
Aussprache und da hat Maximilian
mörseburg für die CDU CSU als erstes das
Wort sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sowohl
die Pandemie als auch die Energiekrise
sind in der Lage Menschen im Land die
Politik und die Gesellschaft als Ganzes
bis zum Äußersten zu fordern das allein
sehr geehrter Herr Minister Heil
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir für die
beiden Krisen dieselben Werkzeuge nutzen
können denn auch wenn es gefühlt
ähnliche Situationen sind unterscheiden
sie sich insbesondere wirtschaftlich
deutlich voneinander im ersten Lockdown
mussten wir völlig gesunde Unternehmen
von einem Tag auf den anderen
dichtmachen lassen Millionen von
Arbeitnehmern werden innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit auf auf der Straße
gestanden wenn wir sie nicht vor allem
eben auch mit dem Kurzarbeitergeld
aufgefangen hätten heute hingegen finden
wir nach den zwei schwierigen Jahren oft
bereits angeschlagene Unternehmen vor
die eigentlich produzieren könnten aber
bei denen es sich nicht mehr lohnt
aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise die
sich einfach nicht mehr leisten können
und da so alles knapp wird werden die
Produkte die diese produzieren auch
immer rare und dann eben noch teurer um
diese Spirale zu durchbrechen dürfen wir
unsere Unternehmen jetzt auf keinen Fall
dicht machen lassen sie müssen also so
lange wie möglich offen gehalten werden
um den angebotsschock nicht noch weiter
zu beschleunigen also um die Nachfrage
eben auch weiter mit Produkten bedienen
zu können Unternehmen die wie Minister
Habig sagen würde einfach aufhören zu
produzieren dürfen aber gar keine
Kurzarbeit anmelden gestiegene
Energiepreise erfüllen eben nicht die
Voraussetzungen zum Anmelden von
Kurzarbeit das hat auch die öffentliche
Anhörung ganz deutlich zeigt und ihnen
zeigt das es ist eben nicht dieselbe Art
von Notlage in der wir stecken wieder
rechtlich noch wirtschaftlich anstatt
auf die altenselben Rezepte zu setzen
haben sie ja eben auch heute eine Reihe
andere Maßnahmen verkündet sie wollen
200 Milliarden Euro Schulden machen um
einen Schirm über den Energiesektor zu
spannen sie wollen so die Preise senken
von paar Tagen hat der Finanzminister
noch betont dass eben nicht jede
Belastung abgefährt werden kann heute
klang es anders am Ende haben sie sich
auf was geeinigt das ist jetzt so aber
dann stellt sich dann stellt sich die
Frage
ob diese 200 Milliarden Euro Schulden
nicht auch die bessere Lösung sind ob
wir damit nicht auch für den
Arbeitsmarkt besser für den Arbeitsmarkt
bessere Maßnahmen mit leisten die
Regierungsfraktion wollen zusätzlich
aber die Bundesregierung ermächtigen
wieder
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu
übernehmen und Kurzarbeit auch
Kurzarbeitergeld auch dann auszahlen
bevor Urlaub und Überstunden abgebaut
sind das klingt natürlich großzügig aber
die Frage die sich dann stellt wie haben
sie das finanziert der Blick in den
Haushaltsentwurf zeigt ja sie haben null
Euro für diese Maßnahmen eingestellt
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
auch die Rücklagen der Bundesagentur
sind aufgebraucht es wurde uns ja auch
noch mal eindrücklich aus der
Bundesagentur mitgeteilt sie wollen sie
wollen die Beiträge aus der
Arbeitslosenversicherung nutzen dafür
wird aber die Erhöhung auch 2,6 Prozent
sicherlich nicht ausreichen wir können
uns keine
schwindelerregend hohen Sozialbeiträge
leisten sie können uns ja zu diesem
Zeitpunkt noch nicht mal sagen wie viel
diese Maßnahmen Kosten werden sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sie wissen
nicht einmal wie viel Leute von diesen
Maßnahmen profitieren werden das ist
einfach keine solide Grundlage um so
etwas heute zu beschließen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
wenn Sie das Kurzarbeitergeld wirklich
als Instrument in der Energiekrise
einsetzen wollen dann sollten Sie ein
krisenkurzarbeitergeld schaffen das
steuerfinanziert ist und das eben auch
im Haushalt mit Geld hinterlegt ist weil
die Rücklagen sind nicht mehr da
Kurzarbeitergeld per se meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ist für die
cdu/csu ein herzenland liegen wir haben
es nicht nur in den letzten Jahren
gemeinsam mit unserem Koalitionspartner
von der SPD genutzt um Deutschland durch
die Krisen zu steuern sondern wir haben
es selbst 1956 ins Gesetz geschrieben
deshalb stehen wir auch weiter zu diesem
Instrument vor dem aktuellen Hintergrund
werden wir aber eine Veränderung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes nämlich der
Ausweitung in der jetzigen Lage nicht
zustimmen es ist wirtschaftspolitisch
einfach nicht angezeigt und die Beiträge
der Arbeitslosenversicherung sind
einfach auch nicht Verfügungsmasse für
ihre Krisenpolitik wenn Sie ein Krisen
Kurzarbeitergeld schaffen wollen dann
hinterlegen Sie es mit Steuermitteln im
Haushalt dann können wir uns noch mal
überlegen ob wir Sie dabei unterstützen
vielen Dank
Maximilian Merseburg warnt hier vor
diesem Gesetzentwurf und der damit
verbundenen längeren vereinfachten
Zugangsmöglichkeit zum Kurzarbeitergeld
auch der Bundesrechnungshof hat schon
sich negativ dazu geäußert
Präsidentin Herr Minister Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste
kurzarbeit ist ein bewährtes Instrument
stabilisiert in Krisenzeiten
nachweislich Beschäftigung das hat sich
schon in der Finanzkrise gezeigt und das
war auch so in Zeiten von Corona und das
gilt auch jetzt für die Krise nach dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und dessen energiepolitischen folgen
dass Ihr Baby bezeichnet den
Arbeitsmarkt zwar im Moment noch als
robust aber das kann sich schnell ändern
wenn Produktion reduziert werden müssen
oder wenn Lieferketten Reisen und dann
ist es gut dass die Bundesregierung
schnell reagieren kann denn als
Kurzarbeitergeld hilft sofort
unmittelbar und das ist dann auch
wichtig für die Unternehmen
in der Anhörung am Montag haben
Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften die
Gesetzentwurf einhellig begrüßt alle
wissen dass Krisenzeiten durch
Kurzarbeit abgefedert und überbrückt
werden können Beschäftigte werden nicht
arbeitslos und die Unternehmen wollen
auch ihre Beschäftigten in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten halten auch wegen dem
Fach- und Arbeitskräftemangel in der
Anhörung wahr zu spüren dass alle
zumindest fast alle die Union eben nicht
an einem Strang ziehen und diese
Solidarität das alle zusammenhalten ist
wichtig und wird dieser besonderen
Situation auch gerecht
bei der Anhörung wurden aber auch
Probleme angesprochen die wir im
Zusammenhang mit dem Kurzarbeitergeld
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren dürfen da
ist die Sorge der Bundesagentur für
Arbeiters eine erneut hohe Zahl an
Anträgen nicht bewältigt werden kann
weil die BA eben damit beschäftigt ist
noch die Abschlussprüfung aus der
corona-zeit zu absolvieren hier müssen
Änderungen im Verfahren oder sogar ein
neues Instrument ein Krisen
Kurzarbeitergeld diskutiert werden wenn
die Bundesagentur für Arbeit das so
deutlich sagt dann müssen wir das
natürlich auch ernst nehmen
und dann gibt es da auch die Regelung
dass ein Minijob bei Bezug von
kurzarbeitergeldanrechnungsfrei bleibt
diese Regelung überdeckt ein Problem und
zwar dass das Kurzarbeitergeld bei
kleinen Einkommen zu niedrig ist und
nicht zum Leben reicht hier gibt es
definitiv Handlungsbedarf mit dem wir
uns ernsthaft beschäftigen müssen
das war kurz der Blick nach vorne heute
aber geht es darum die Bundesregierung
handlungsfähig zu machen damit sie mit
dem Kurzarbeitergeld eine Brücke bauen
kann die den Unternehmen und den
Beschäftigten wenn es notwendig wird
wirklich hilft denn wir wollen natürlich
alles dafür tun um Entlassungen und
Arbeitslosigkeit zu verhindern die Union
hat gestern im Ausschuss dagegen
gestimmt hat es jetzt eben noch mal
gesagt ich kann es überhaupt nicht
verstehen und die die Argumente sind
extrem schwach und trotzdem hoffe ich
dennoch jetzt auf eine breite
Unterstützung vielen Dank
Beate Müller Gemmeke war das hier
zum
Kurzarbeitergeld nächster Redner ist
Hannes Gnauck er spricht für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der Winter naht und man merkt ihnen auf
der Regierungsbank wird allmählich warm
ganz im Gegensatz zum Großteil der
Bevölkerung wir sehen mit der
Veränderung dieser
Verordnungsermächtigung beim
Kurzarbeitergeld den Auftakt ihr ihrer
kommenden krisen- und protestmanagements
in diesem Winter sie beschneiden hier
natürlich die Handlungsfähigkeit des
Bundestages da Weichenstellungen mit
einem Kostenvolumen dieser Dimension
eigentlich im zuständigkeits- und
Verantwortungsbereich der Legislative
und eben nicht der Exekutive liegen das
Budgetrecht liegt beim Parlament und
Frau Anke Eitner von der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit erklärte im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales noch in dieser Woche
das eine erneute massenhaft den
Anspruchnahme des Kurzarbeitergeldes wie
in den letzten zwei Jahren während ihrer
unverhältnismäßigen corona-maßnahmen
nicht zu bewältigen wären die Rücklagen
sind ja bereits jetzt aufgebraucht kurz
gesagt Sie haben gar nicht mehr das Geld
um diesen sozialen Schirm zu finanzieren
aber wenn kümmert es angesichts der
Inflationsrate noch bei ihnen in der
Bundesregierung offenbar niemanden und
zugestanden wir stehen vor solch großen
Verwerfungen das eine flexible
Handlungsfähigkeit der Regierung
notwendig sein wird zumindest da können
wir als afd-fraktion mitgehen und
natürlich ist der primäre Zweck des
ausgeweiteten Kurzarbeitergeldes die
Verhinderung von Massenarbeitslosigkeit
und das ist in einer Krise die oberste
Priorität der politischen Führung das
Kurzarbeitergeld ist allerdings
eigentlich dazu da um im Falle einer
kurzfristigen schlechten Auftragslage
die Arbeitnehmer vor dem Arbeitsverlust
zu schützen aber nicht dafür um alle
Unternehmen unseres Landes ob
wirtschaftlich arbeiten oder nicht zu
subventionieren
sie greifen hier auf eine neoliberale
Politik zurück meine Damen und Herren
die der Dimension der Lage überhaupt
nicht angemessen ist sie öffnen damit
den Missbrauch und negativer
Lenkungseffekte Tür und Tor während
Arbeitnehmer durch verringerten Lohn
steigende Inflation und andauernde
Steuerabgabe dennoch kaputt gepfrifft
werden sie können mit der Veränderung
dieser Regelung vielleicht über den
Winter hinweg unsere
wirtschaftslandschaft strukturell
halbwegs am Leben halten eine echte
Lösung für das Sterben unserer
Industrienation ist es dennoch nicht
meine Damen und Herren
und hier liegt das viel grundlegendere
Problem sie haben sich über Jahrzehnte
mit einem Fokus auf Dienstleistung
grüner Energiewende und wird
außenwirtschaftlicher Einseitigkeit in
eine Lage manövriert in der unser Land
und Codes vor dem Abgrund steht sie
können mit Kurzarbeitergeld die soziale
Frage in Deutschland vielleicht ein
wenig aufschieben lösen werden sie sie
allerdings nicht ganz im Gegenteil sie
wird sich in den kommenden Wochen und
Monaten bloß noch zuspitzen was wir hier
sehen ist das typische Handlungsmuster
vor allem von dieser von Verfehlung
getriebenen Bundesregierung die
Problemzusammenhänge sind dermaßen
komplex dass die Krise zum Dauerzustand
geworden ist sie nutzen staatliche
Instrumente die ursprünglich für
kurzfristige Notstände vorgesehen waren
und machen sie zum permanenten Werkzeug
ihres Verfalls meines Managements das
Krisenregime dass ich in diesem Hause
langsam anbahnt wird sich jeder Beratung
entziehen von uns als parlamentarische
Opposition ja sowieso das haben bei
Corona schon gesehen aber auch der
volksprotest interessiert sie ja Frau
bärburg im nicht im geringsten und
deshalb muss sich der Protest der Bürger
schleunigst konzentrieren meine Damen
und Herren dazu möchte ich abschließend
noch einmal alle mit Betteln aufrufen um
am achten Oktober mit uns als AFD hier
in der Hauptstadt als geeinter
volksprotest auf die Straße zu gehen
insbesondere auch jene die von
Kurzarbeit betroffen sind damit es nicht
bei permanenter Kurzarbeit grüner
Deindustrialisierung und Massenverarmung
bleibt und damit die Entscheidungsträger
dieses Hohen Hauses mal wieder an ihren
Amtseid erinnert werden denn in der
Bundesrepublik meine Damen und Herren in
der Bundesrepublik ist und bleibt der
Souverän das deutsche Volk vielen Dank
Hannes genau war das hat hier sich noch
mal für Demonstrationen ausgesprochen
dass Mark allerdings zum Beispiel dabei
Demonstration von Fridays for future
etwas anders klingen aber das nur eine
Vermutung Pascal Kuba spricht jetzt für
die FDP-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Kurzarbeitergeld ist ein
Erfolg es ist ein notwendiger Erfolg in
einer schwierigen Situation viele
Experten in anderen Ländern beneiden uns
um dieses Instrument es ermöglicht die
Wahrung und Sicherung der Existenz
vieler Arbeitsplätze auch wenn wir nicht
verschweigen dürfen dass es einhergeht
für viele mit Einkommensverlusten und
deshalb natürlich die Sorgen auf der
einen Seite mildert aber gleichzeitig
auch nicht jede Sorge beseitigen kann
und ich möchte auch darauf hinweisen
dass es ein Vorteil ist für die
Unternehmen
denn auch die Unternehmen können nach
der schwierigen Phase in der sie
Kurzarbeit der Geld beantragen mussten
mit ihren eingeübten und bewerten
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern sofort
den Schwung der dann vielleicht wieder
entsteht aber Arbeitsmarkt bzw in der
Wirtschaft die Entwicklung nutzen um
dann wieder Produkte auf den Markt zu
bringen und ich möchte mich ausdrücklich
bei denjenigen unter den
Unternehmerinnen Unternehmern bedanken
die aus eigenen Mitteln das
Kurzarbeitergeld aufgestockt haben das
ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit und das
sollte hier nicht unerwähnt bleiben
was auch nicht unerwähnt bleiben sollte
sind die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
die diesen erhöhten
anstörung auf Kurzarbeitergeld die
erhöhten Zahlen anmeldungen für
Kurzarbeit bewältigt haben und der hohen
persönlichen Einsatz mit hoher
persönlicher Motivation und nur durch
diese Motivation der Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit war es am Ende möglich auch
möglichst schnell die Hilfe zur
Verfügung zu stellen herzlichen Dank
dafür
besonders freut mich in diesem
Zusammenhang auch dass es auf unsere
Initiative hin gelungen ist dass wir
auch die Kurzarbeit gerade in der drei
Monaten jetzt zwischen 1 oktober und dem
31 Dezember dass wir da die Zeitarbeit
auch wieder mit in der Kurzarbeit
berücksichtigen können übrigens es wäre
vielleicht auch mal an der Zeit darüber
nachzudenken ob der Begriff Leiharbeit
für Zeitarbeiter noch angemessen ist
denn es sagt schon etwas aus über das
Bild der Menschen die in einem
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
Beschäftigungsverhältnis arbeiten wenn
wir Sie als Leiharbeiter bezeichnen ich
glaube hier sollten wir noch mal darüber
nachdenken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
sollten aber auch nicht verschweigen
dass Kurzarbeit ein teures Instrument
ist es sind die genauen Zahlen liegen ja
noch nicht vor aber man darf davon
ausgehen schon um die 50 Milliarden Euro
plus
aufgewendet worden im Februar sagte der
Chef der Bundesagentur für Arbeit damals
Detlef Scheele das ist 46 Milliarden
Euro gewesen sein plus Steuergeld im
Jahr 2021 wohl von 18 Milliarden Euro es
ist ein teures Instrument es ist ein
notwendiges Instrument aber wir dürfen
nicht verschweigen dass da ein
erhebliche Arbeitsleistung der
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter und auch
der Unternehmen in den guten Zeiten
dahintersteckt überhaupt die Rücklagen
in der Arbeitslosenversicherung
aufzubauen und auch Dank an die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler die
hier einspringen obwohl sie vielleicht
gar nicht persönlich von Kurzarbeit
betroffen sind eine große solidarische
Leistung dieser Gesellschaft alle helfen
zusammen ganz großartig herzlichen Dank
dafür
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
Krise die wir bisher kannten im
Wesentlichen Corona mit den bisherigen
Erfahrungen bei der Kurzarbeit sich
vielleicht in den nächsten Monaten noch
ganz anders gestalten wird deshalb ist
es wichtig dass wir hier die richtigen
Maßnahmen treffen die Bundesregierung
hat sich gerade darauf verständigt wie
die Energiepreise im Griff behalten
werden können dass es eine wichtige
Entscheidung weil es notwendig ist dass
wir natürlich auch die
Kostensteigerungen für die Unternehmen
im Blick behalten und auch da möchten
wir als FDP in dieser Koalition daran
erinnern dass wir unternehmen auch
dadurch entlasten können dass wir sie
nicht nur dauernd neu belasten und da
hat das Arbeitsrecht natürlich auch
seinen Anteil dran ich würde mich freuen
wenn wir bei der Nachweis Richtlinie
noch mal drauf schauen könnten dass wir
Chancen der Digitalisierung nutzen die
uns die EU auch einräumt das würde viele
Unternehmen entlasten und da wäre es
glaube ich angebracht an der Stelle noch
einmal zu prüfen ob wir hier nicht zu
Entlastungen kommen könnten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir kämpfen alle gemeinsam für die
Bewältigung der Krise der energiekrieg
Putins gegen die freie Welt gegen unsere
Volkswirtschaft gegen unsere
Gesellschaft wird keinen Erfolg haben
dafür steht diese Regierung solidarisch
mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zusammen
wir schaffen auch diese Herausforderung
da bin ich zuversichtlich vielen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle ganz herzlich am
Donnerstagnachmittag spüre die Frische
im Raum die jetzt sicherlich noch mal in
dieser Debatte hervorkommt und das Wort
erhält Jessica tatti für die Fraktion
DIE LINKE
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Beschäftigten
und Betrieben steht ein harter Winter
bevor die Unsicherheit ist groß und
deshalb stimmt die Linke dem
Gesetzentwurf zum Kurzarbeitergeld
selbstverständlich zu
dingsminister
Heinzi dieses Gesetz jetzt auch für
Verbesserungen greifen Sie doch einfach
mal die sehr guten Vorschläge meiner
Fraktion auf zum Beispiel die Einführung
eines mindest Kurzarbeitergeldes von
1.200 Euro für Vollzeitkräfte oder die
Erhöhung des Kurzarbeitergeldes auf 90%
von netto also das wäre total sinnvoll
bei diesen krassen Preissteigerungen und
nicht zuletzt
es kann doch nicht sein dass Unternehmen
die Kurzarbeit in Anspruch nehmen
gleichzeitig horrende Boni an Manager
und hohe Dividenden an ihre Aktionäre
ausschütten das ist völlig unangemessen
und muss endlich unterbunden werden und
jetzt zuhören Herr mörseburg von der
Unionsfraktion denn derzeit kann das
Kurzarbeitergeld eben nicht mehr aus
Beiträgen finanziert werden sondern muss
aus Steuermitteln bezahlt das heißt von
der Allgemeinheit getragen werden die
Rücklagen der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
sind nach Corona schon lange verbraucht
während der Pandemie mussten weit über
20 Milliarden Euro aus Steuermitteln
zugeschossen werden und das war auch
richtig so weil damit Arbeitsplätze
erhalten wurden und deshalb wird das
auch weiterhin richtig sein
denn diese Krise wären Ausgangspunkt der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg war
ist eine politische Krise und deshalb
Pascal Kober ist die Finanzierung der
Kurzarbeit auch eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe
so unverzichtbar das Kurzarbeitergeld
auch ist noch besser wäre es natürlich
zu verhindern dass überhaupt wieder
massenhaft Beschäftigte in die
Kurzarbeit gehen müssen das ganze
Industriezweige ins Wanken geraten muss
verhindert werden die Chaos-Tage der
Bundesregierung gasumlage ja jetzt
wieder nein Gaspreise Deckeln gestern
noch nein heute doch ja dieses Chaos der
Bundesregierung ist für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger für die Betriebe in denen
Beschäftigte Angst um ihren Arbeitsplatz
haben und zumutbar wie viel Zeit ging
dadurch ins Land stoppen Sie die
Preisexplosion sichern sie die
Produktion mit einem wirksamen
gaspreisdeckel
Kolleginnen und Kollegen richten sie
Bundeskanzler Scholz doch bitte
herzliche Grüße von mir aus ich erwarte
nämlich von ihm dass er beim nächsten
Treffen der konzertierten Aktion wenn er
sich mit den Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgeberverbänden trifft mal nachhakt
warum nutzen die Betriebe eigentlich die
Zeit von Kurzarbeit nicht viel stärker
für Weiterbildung ihrer Beschäftigten in
der Transformation die Fakten
Kurzarbeiter Namen in der Pandemie
wesentlich Selter immer an
Weiterbildungen teil als andere
Beschäftigte und wenn doch
Weiterbildungen stattfanden dann für
Beschäftigte mit Hochschulabschluss neun
Mal häufiger als für Leute die gar
keinen Abschluss haben und das ist doch
wirklich eine eine wirklich
katastrophale Bilanz
also hier ist noch massiv was zu tun
sofort anfangen könnten sie im übrigen
Herr Heil mit der Stärkung der
Mitbestimmung mit der Stärkung von
Betriebs- und Personalräten denn dort wo
es Betriebsräte gibt finden auch mehr
Weiterbildungen statt auch für die
Kurzarbeit und deshalb fangen Sie damit
endlich an
die Forderung von Jessica Tati der
arbeitsmarktpolitischen Sprecherin der
Linken auf sie antworten wird jetzt Jens
Park für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
fangen wir mal mit der guten Nachricht
an unser Arbeitsmarkt ist robust
trotz drohender Rezession sind wieder
mehr Menschen in Arbeit trotz der realen
Gefahr einer gasmangellade suchen
Unternehmen Händeringen Fachkräfte in
diesem Land ohne diese dunklen Wolke am
Horizont werden wir heute voller
Zuversicht auf einen ungetrübten
Arbeitsmarkt schauen aber wegen dieses
getrübten Ausblicks verlängern wir hier
und heute die Verordnungsermächtigung
für die Sonderregelungen des
Kurzarbeitergeldes dem erfolgreichsten
kriseninstrument in der corona-pandemie
und das ist richtig so dass es richtig
so weil dieser Gesetzentwurf den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
den Unternehmen Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit für die Zukunft gibt mit
dieser Verordnungsermächtigung machen
wir den Arbeitsmarkt weiterhin
krisenfest
in der corona-pandemie haben wir gesehen
was die Sonderregelungen des
Kurzarbeitergeldes können in dieser
bisher schwersten Wirtschaftskrise der
Nachkriegszeit haben über fünf Millionen
Menschen durch die Sonderregelungen des
Kurzarbeitergeldes ihren Job behalten
können
und die Kritiker der Sonderregelung wir
haben es ja gerade aufgehört Fragen dann
immer zu welchem Preis ja es hat die
Reserven der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
aufgebraucht ja es hat viel Geld
gekostet insgesamt über 45 Milliarden
auch wenn wir die konkrete Zahlen noch
nicht haben aber in der Anhörung am
Montag zu diesem Gesetzentwurf hat die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit noch einmal
ganz klar gesagt was es uns gekostet
hätte wenn wir diese Regelung nicht
gehabt hätten
wer in Kurzarbeit ist der braucht
monatlich bekommt monatlich
Unterstützung in Höhe von ca 38 Euro wer
aber arbeitslos wird muss mit 1.850 Euro
aus der Arbeitslosenversicherung
unterstützt werden das heißt ohne
Kurzarbeitergeld wäre diese Krise mehr
als doppelt so teuer geworden und dabei
reden wir noch nicht über dieser
wichtigen sozialen Folgekosten und
volkswirtschaftlichen denn was das mit
dem einzelnen macht was es für Familien
bedeutet wenn man arbeitslos wird welche
Sorgen und Probleme dann verbunden ist
das lässt sich nicht in eures ausdrücken
und auch von den immer wieder an die
Wand gemalten Schreckenszenarien
beim Kurzarbeitergeld ist kein einziges
eingetreten nein es lässt sich keine
Entwöhnung der Menschen von der Arbeit
feststellen nein es gab nach der
corona-pandemie keine zombie-firmen die
einfach in Insolvenz gegangen sind und
nein es gibt auch keine Anzeichen dafür
dass der Strukturwandel verschleppt
wurde ganz im Gegenteil dass wir ein
robusten Arbeitsmarkt haben dass wir
eine schnelle Erholung der
Beschäftigtenzahlen haben das ist der
Verdienst des Kurzarbeitergeldes so
sieht gute Arbeitsmarktpolitik aus
und deswegen ist es folgerichtig heute
der Bundesregierung weiterhin die
Möglichkeit zu geben diese Instrumente
zu nutzen und es ist vollkommen klar
dass das nicht ausreicht dass das ein
Baustein in der Krisenbekämpfung ist um
nichts anderes geht es doch natürlich
brauchen wir flankierende
Wirtschaftshilfen um Insolvenzen zu
verhindern natürlich braucht es
entlastungspakete und einem vor allem
eine energiepreisdeckel für Gas und
Strom sowie auch heute von der
Bundesregierung auf beschlossen wurde
und wir brauchen auch
Daseinsvorsorge in öffentlicher Hand
wieder Fall uniper zeigt und natürlich
müssen wir auch krisenprofiteuren die
Pflicht nehmen am besten mit einer
übergewinnsteuer
und ich will noch eins kurz sagen zur
Kritik der CDU von der mörseburg
natürlich rechtfertigen gestiegende
Preise beim Gas keine Kurzarbeit das ist
Betriebsrisiko aber liefer Engpässe
Tunes und auch die sind doch nicht
ausgeschlossen durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine und auch eine Gas magellage
würde es tun und natürlich ist das
kurzarbeit kann Dauerlösung aber Krisen
sollen es auch
nicht zur Krise gibt reagieren wir auch
was die CDU macht ist an der Stelle aber
vollkommen unklar im Fachausschuss haben
sie dagegen gestimmt im
Haushaltsausschuss haben sich enthalten
sie ihr Licht dann durch die Krise und
ich bin gespannt was sie gleich tun
werden ich kann Ihnen nur sagen stimmen
sie zu weil mit diesen vorigen
Gesetzentwurf machen wir den
Arbeitsmarkt krisenfest dass es gut so
geht Politik die den Menschen hilft
herzlichen Dank
wie können die Unternehmen in dieser
schwierigen Zeit unterstützt werden
Menschen vor Arbeitslosigkeit geschützt
werden ohne zu hohe Sozialausgaben zu
haben darüber diskutieren hier die
Abgeordneten als nächstes Axel knörig
für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
zuhören und zuhören
zunächst möchte ich ganz klar
feststellen dass Kurzarbeitergeld hat
uns während der Pandemie einen guten
Dienst erwiesen wir haben in Deutschland
keine massenhafte Arbeitslosigkeit
gesehen der Arbeitsmarkt ist stabil
geblieben das war schlichtweg gut für
die Beschäftigten denn sie wussten dass
ihre Arbeitsplätze abgesichert werden
zugleich war es gut für die Unternehmen
die Arbeitgeber konnten ihre Mitarbeiter
nicht nur halten sondern hatten nach der
Pandemie die Möglichkeit wieder
durchzustarten es war da ja richtig den
Zugang zum Kurzarbeitergeld zum
vereinfachen und weitere
Sonderregelungen einzuführen
dennoch war schon damals klar dass das
Instrument eigentlich nicht für solche
Fälle gedacht ist die Ressourcen der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit und zu lassen
ihrer Hauptaufgaben beansprucht
trotzdem war das Kurzarbeitergeld der
richtige Weg nun haben wir aber eine
völlig andere Situation
wir waren in der Pandemie gezwungen die
Wirtschaft allgemein herunterzufahren
deshalb war das breit angelegte
Kurzarbeitergeld ein gutes Konzept jetzt
müssen wir viel mehr verhindern dass
Bestand bestimmte Branchen lahmgelegt
werden wir brauchen zielgerichtete
Hilfen für energieintensive Unternehmen
liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
sicheren sich wenn sie das
Kurzarbeitergeld als Mittel gegen die
hohen Energiekosten einsetzen wollen der
Weg ist nicht nur einfach falsch
errichtet auch Schaden an Sie stellen
sich das Kurzarbeitergeld als
Liquiditätshilfe für kleinere und
mittlere Unternehmen vor aber diese
Vorstellung geht schlichtweg an der
Realität vorbei fakt ist
das Kurzarbeitergeld dient dazu
beschäftigungsausfälle zu begrenzen und
ich möchte sie Herr Minister und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Koalition
daran erinnern wir haben derzeit in
Deutschland 1,9 Millionen unbesetzte
Stellen wie können Sie das Vergessen für
seine eigentlichen Aufgabe wird das
Kurzarbeiter Geld auf weiter benötigt
aber ist doch kein Instrument für jede
Krise
zeitlich überschaubare Ausfälle aus
konjunkturellen Gründen müssen natürlich
auch in Zukunft aufgefangen werden daran
rüttelt auch niemand statt die
Sonderregeln zu verlängern muss unser
Ziel doch nun sein möglichst viele
Betriebe am Laufen zu halten unser
Mittelstand der ruft doch seit Wochen
und Monaten um Hilfe aber von ihnen
kommt keine Antwort
im Herbst und im Winter das werden wir
erleben wird es zu umfangreichen
Betriebsschließung kommen können da geht
es nicht um ein temporäres pausieren wie
das sehr Herbig sagte sondern um das
dauerhafte Verschwinden von Unternehmen
am Markt sorgen sie endlich dafür dass
die Produktion am Laufen bleibt und
unsere Unternehmen und Arbeitnehmer
weiterarbeiten können
sie wissen es
sie wissen es und Frau Nahles weiß es
auch der finanzielle Spielraum der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die es
aufgebraucht das Kurzarbeitergeld müssen
Sie in Zukunft aus Steuermitteln
finanzieren oder neue Schulden aufnehmen
müssen keine guten Perspektive in der
Folge wird die hohe Inflation weiter
angeheizt die Preise steigen und die
Krise verschärft sich noch mehr wenn Sie
diesen Weg weitergehen werden sie
politisch scheitern scheitern werden
aber auch tausende von Unternehmen und
ihre beschäftigen Beschäftigten und das
wollen wir nicht verkraften wir fordern
vom Bundesarbeitsministerium seit über
einem Jahr das Kurzarbeitergeld
weiterzuentwickeln ganz besonders muss
dabei auch Qualifizierung und
Weiterbildung berücksichtigt werden das
wurde in den Phasen der Kurzarbeit
bislang nicht ausreichend umgesetzt wir
müssen noch unsere Beschäftigten das
richtige Rüstzeug mitgeben damit Sie
auch in Zukunft den Wandel der
Arbeitswelt bestehen können
und das ist nicht unser O-Ton das ist
der O-Ton der Bundesagentur sie waren
sogar davor dass die Kurzarbeit
notwendige Transformationsprozesse in
Betrieben verhindert wir hätten schon
lange Lösungen entwickelt werden müssen
und liebe Kollegen es ist deutlich
geworden wir brauchen in dieser Krise
neue Konzepte um den Arbeitsmarkt auf
Kurs zu halten dabei müssen wir die
langfristigen Trends doch im Auge
behalten und vor allen Dingen den Wandel
des Arbeitsmarktes der Arbeitswelt nicht
verschlafen und ganz akut müssen doch
unsere Betriebe bei den hohen
Energiekosten unterstützt werden und sie
machen heute das Gegenteil sie
zweckentfremden und überladen das
Kurzarbeitergeld und dem können wir
nicht zustimmen
um das Kurzarbeitergeld zu enthalten
lehnen wir Ihren Gesetzesentwurf ab
danke für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
war das und damit können wir schon zum
vorletzten Redner hier in dieser Debatte
bevor dann die Abgeordneten darüber
abstimmen ob auch in Zukunft verlängert
das vereinfachten Zugang zum
Kurzarbeitergeld gibt bis zum Mitte den
des kommenden Jahres Wolfgang Strickmann
Kuhn spricht jetzt oder auch Herr
mörseburg warum sie das Gesetz ablehnen
ist mehr als dünn und wirklich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar
an einem Punkt haben sie recht wir sind
in einer anderen ökonomischen Situation
als zum Beginn der corona-krise zu
Beginn der corona-krise war das
Kurzarbeitergeld das zentrale Mittel aus
den Gründen die wir alle kennen jetzt
ist es ein Mittel aber ein wichtiges
Mittel wir stehen vor einer drohenden
Rezession aufgrund eines preisschocks
der verursacht worden ist durch den
Angriffskrieg von Putin
und darauf müssen wir reagieren eine
Rezession fällt nicht vom Himmel sondern
wir sind da handlungsfähig und wir
können dagegen angehen die
Energieversorgung muss sichergestellt
werden da ist die Bundesregierung seit
Dezember letzten Jahres dran und die
Energiespeicher sind gefüllt wir
entlasten die Menschen ganz wichtiger
Punkt und es sind ja noch nicht mal alle
entlastungspakete umgesetzt das läuft
also wir machen Unterstützung für die
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen und
sonst für die Wirtschaft das hat heute
die Bundesregierung beschlossen und auch
mit finanziellen Mitteln hinterlegt das
ist sehr gut
die gasumlage brauchen wir nicht
einzuführen weil wir haben das
finanziell anders geregelt ganz im
Gegenteil zu ihren Forderungen zu
Ablehnung der gasumlage das ist gut dass
die gasumlage weg ist und dass die
Gegenfinanzierung gesichert ist
und es ist gut dass jetzt noch mal
konkretisiert worden ist dass wir in die
preismärkte einsteigen und gucken dass
wir einen gaspreisdeckel und einen Strom
Deckel hinkriegen und auch das ist
sinnvoll
und wir sind vor der vor einer Rezession
und die 200 Milliarden Euro die die
Bundesregierung heute vorgeschlagen hat
die wir ja erst noch bearbeiten müssen
im Bundestag haben das Zeug dazu dass es
ein regelrechtes Konjunkturprogramm sein
kann und auch das ist in der jetzigen
Situation richtig weil wir müssen ja
nicht nur auf das Angebot gucken bei so
einem Preisschock sondern auch auf die
Nachfrage und sicherstellen dass Sie
Nachfrage auch sichergestellt wird und
auch das macht die Bundesregierung genau
richtig
so und wir wissen die Arbeitsmärkte sind
sehr robust und es ist nicht mal klar ob
eine schwache Rezession überhaupt auf
die Arbeitsmärkte durchschlägt so warum
macht das Gesetz aber trotzdem Sinn
aus zwei Gründen erstens und das ist
noch gar nicht gesagt worden Corona ist
noch nicht vorbei die herbstwelle läuft
und nimmt zunehmend an Fahrt auf und wir
wissen nicht wie heftig das in diesem
Herbst und Winter noch wird und darauf
müssen wir vorbereitet sein
und der zweite Punkt ist wir sind nicht
hilflos gegen der ökonomischen
Entwicklung aber die Entwicklung ist so
schwierig vorherzusehen und auch die
prognoseinstrumente der ökonomischen
Institute sind da relativ unklar ist
kann sein bei allen Anstrengungen die
wir gemeinsam machen dass es doch
heftiger wird und auch darauf müssen wir
vorbereitet sein und deswegen ist es
eine Verordnungsermächtigung damit es im
Fall des Falles schnell die
Bundesregierung reagieren kann damit wir
Arbeitsplätze sichern können und das ist
genau der richtige Weg und dem sollten
alle demokratischen Parteien hier
zustimmen vielen Dank
und die letzte Rednerin in der Debatte
ist Natalie public sie sitzt für die
Sozialdemokraten im Ausschuss für Arbeit
und Soziales
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verehrte
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer es wurde
heute von einem Teil der
ParlamentarierInnen Parlamentarier
deutlich aber vor allem wurde das diese
Woche in der öffentlichen Anhörung
seitens der Expertinnen und Experten aus
den Gewerkschaften von den
Wirtschaftsverbänden von der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit aus der
Wissenschaft deutlich dass
Kurzarbeitergeld ist und war eine
wesentliche Stütze die uns durch
Krisenzeiten führt und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir das heute hier
verlängern
Beschäftigung zu fördern und
Arbeitsplätze gerade in Krisenzeiten zu
sichern das ist der Kern
sozialdemokratischer Politik und genau
dafür sorgen wir heute mit der
Verlängerung
drei Jahre corona-pandemie und die
bisherigen folgende schrecklichen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskriegs
Russlands auf die Ukraine haben unsere
Wirtschaft und unseren Arbeitsmarkt
nicht in den Ruinen getrieben
das sieht man auch zum Beispiel bei mir
zu Hause in Südhessen dort konnten wir
wegen des Kurzarbeitergeldes zahlreiche
Unternehmen am Industrie- und
Dienstleistungsstandort halten und
Beschäftigung sichern
Millionen Arbeitsplätze konnten und
können durch die Kurzarbeit erhalten
werden das sind nicht nur Zahlen das
sind Menschen dahinter stehen Familien
dass dahinter stehen Existenzen die
davor bewahrt werden konnten mitten in
einer wirtschaftlichen Ausnahmesituation
in Arbeitslosigkeit zu geraten und eine
in eine ungewisse Zukunft zu schauen und
das ist auch wichtig hierbei zu betonen
aber es ist eben nicht nur die
Perspektive aus seitens der
Beschäftigten dafür dass Kurzarbeit ein
erfolgsinstrument ist für uns als
Gesamtgesellschaft ist Kurzarbeit
wesentlich günstiger als die
Finanzierung von Arbeitslosigkeit für
unsere Unternehmen stellt Kurzarbeit
sicher dass Sie sich schnell von Krisen
erholen können und handlungsfähig
bleiben weil sie gute Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter eben nicht gehen lassen
müssen es sind viele Instrumente die wir
gerade in diesen Krisenzeiten auf dem
Weg bringen es sind preisbremsen das
sind entlastungspakete es sind der 12
Euro Mindestlohn das sind des Bürgergeld
das wir auf dem Weg bringen werden und
viele viele andere Maßnahmen die wir
derzeit tätigen die uns alle zusammen
durch diese Krise und diesen Winter
führen werden und so zu tun als würde
die Bundesregierung gar nichts tun ich
schlichtweg falsch
und Herr knörike ich wundere mich
tatsächlich was sie hier vorgetragen
haben denn die Regelungen zu
Qualifizierung in der Kurzarbeit haben
wir in der großen Koalition gemeinsam
noch in der letzten Legislaturperiode
auf den Weg gebracht und so zu tun als
gäbe es die nicht ist ebenfalls falsch
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir leben gerade in Zeiten
in denen viele politische Kräfte und
gerade hier an meiner rechten Seite
gerne dieses Land der Boden sehen würden
die mit politischen Kräften und
Kriegsverbrechern zusammenarbeiten die
lieber Gas sinnlos verbrennen statt das
nach Europa zu schicken
doch bei all den Schwierigkeiten und bei
all den Herausforderungen die wir
zusammen zu meistern haben und bei all
den dich inhaltlichen Differenzen die
wir unter der demokratischen Parteien um
den das in dem Ringen um den richtigen
Weg haben bin ich fest davon überzeugt
dass wir als Gesellschaft und als
Demokratie stärker sind als die
Kriegsverbrecher dieser Welt und wir
alles dafür tun sollten diese
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten vielen
Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Anpassung der Verordnungsermächtigung
beim Kurzarbeitergeld und anderer
Regelungen der Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 37/21
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grüne und FDP auf
Drucksache 34 94 anzunehmen ich bitte
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen das
ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
cdu/csu wer enthält sich das ist die AFD
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen wir kommen zur
dritten Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
dass es wiederum die Linke SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die cdu/csu-fraktion und wer
enthält sich das ist die AFD damit ist
der Gesetzentwurf endgültig angenommen
so das war also dann die Abstimmung zum
Kurzarbeitergeld da wird hier auch noch
mal applaudiert und wir schauen schon
mal auf den nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt
es geht um einen Antrag der Fraktionen
der cdu/csu und zwar nämlich wie mit dem
Wolf umgegangen wird und wie eben dort
er geschützt wird aber natürlich auch
der Mensch und sein Hab und Gut
geschützt werden kann die Unionsfraktion
erfordert dass sich Deutschland da an
EU-Staaten wie Schweden Finnland oder
Frankreich orientiert und zum Beispiel
auch das Bundesjagdgesetz ändert das
würde bedeuten dass nämlich der Wolf in
den Katalog der jagdbaren Arten
aufgenommen wird momentan ist er ja noch
streng geschützt und das ist dann in der
Debatte mitunter schwierig genaueres
wird uns Klaus im Markt dazu sagen er
ist einerseits
Mitglied der Unionsfraktion aber war
auch 2006 bis 2021 Bürgermeister in der
Stadt Bad Wildbach und Bad Wildbach
machte unter anderem 2018 Schlagzeilen
als dort einen Wolf tatsächlich 32
Schafe gerissen hat
ja frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ein Bürgermeister aus
Sachsen berichtet von einem Wolfsrudel
das tagsüber durchs dorfschleicht Kinder
gehen dort aus Angst nicht mehr zu Fuß
zur Schule vorletzte Woche haben Wölfe
eine ganze Alpakaherde ausgelöscht die
Zäune wurden untergraben inzwischen
müssen in Niedersachsen in Brandenburg
selbst grüne und rote Umweltministerin
Abschuss von Wölfen erleichtern meine
Damen und Herren ich habe die zuständige
Staatssekretärin mit diesen Fragen hier
im Plenum konfrontiert sie meinte dass
Märchen von Rotkäppchen und dem bösen
Wolf sei auserzählt das Märchen ist aber
nicht außer zählt ganz im Gegenteil wir
schlagen gerade ein neues Kapitel auf
und wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln dann
wird es auch kein Happy End geben meine
Damen und Herren
seit dem Jahr 2000 breitet sich der Wolf
exponentiell aus die Bestände wachsen
jährlich um rund 30 Prozent in
Deutschland gibt es mehr als 2000 Wölfe
rechnen Sie das mal auf die nächsten
zehn Jahre hoch dabei ist jetzt schon
klar dass wir beim Wolf von einem
günstigen Erhaltungszustand ausgehen
können und natürlich ist das einer Volk
für den Artenschutz es geht ja auch
nicht darum den Wolf wieder auszurotten
es geht darum den Bestand zu regeln so
wie bei jeder anderen Wildtierart auch
sonst werden wir die Folgen nicht in den
Griff bekommen erkennen sie endlich an
dass der Wolf in manchen Gegenden
Deutschlands schon jetzt zum echten
Problem geworden ist meine Damen und
Herren
wir haben zunehmend Schäden durch
Angriffe auf Weide und Haustiere 2020
wurden allein rund 4.000 Weidetiere
getötet jetzt hat es sogar das Pony
unserer kommissionspräsidentin erwischt
aber das ist ja nur die prominente
Spitze eines Eisbergs es geht um die
vielen weidetierhalter
Präventionsmaßnahmen sind eben nicht
immer wirksam schwere wolfszäune lassen
sich eben nicht immer die steilen Hänge
hinauftragen die weidetierhaltung ist
vielerorts ernsthaft bedroht aber so
weit darf es nicht kommen mit ihren grün
roten Träumereien und einer völlig
falschen Romantisierung des Wolfes
setzen Sie den Erhalt unserer
Kulturlandschaft durch Spiel meine Damen
und Herren
wissen Sie ich war als Bürgermeister
derjenige der im Schwarzwald erstmals
erleben müsste wenn ein Wolf in einer
Nacht im Blutrausch 20 Schafe tötet und
die von hinten angefressenen Körper
morgens noch lebend auf der Weide liegen
offensichtlich wird wir hier wieder
einmal von Berliner Schreibtischen aus
über Probleme sinniert ohne mit den
Menschen vor Ort zu sprechen das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn zwei Wölfe und ein
Schaf darüber abstimmen was es zum
Abendessen gibt meine Damen und Herren
den Menschen den Menschen vor Ort in
ländlichen Raum hilft das aber nichts es
wird hier nur an den Folgen
herumgedocktert das
Bundesumweltministerium weigert sich das
Problem grundlegend anzugehen wir
fordern ein aktives
wolfsbestandsmanagement setzen Sie sich
bei der EU-Kommission dafür ein dass der
Wolf von Anhang 4 in Anhang 5 der
FFH-Richtlinie eingestuft wird lassen
sie uns des Bundesjagdgesetz ändern und
legen Sie wolfsfreie Gebiete fest denn
wo stehen wir heute die Grünen würden am
liebsten mit dem Wolf tanzen und alles
laufen lassen hätte es die SPD bei den
Gebrüdern Grimm schon gegeben wurde
Rotkäppchen wahrscheinlich hinter einem
Schutzzaun sitzen wollen sie am Ende den
ganz Deutschland einzäunen einzig die
FDP weiß eigentlich was zu tun wäre es
sie haben einen entsprechenden Antrag
2018 schon gestellt sie müssen aber
natürlich heute wieder gegen ihre eigene
überzeugungsstimmen dazu sage ich nur
liebe Kollegen von der FDP wer sich
selbst nicht so scharf macht den fressen
am Ende die Wölfe haben Sie den Mut
haben Sie den Mut unseren Antrag zu
unterstützen im Sinne unserer
Landschaftspfleger im Sinne der Menschen
vor Ort helfen Sie mit unsere schöne
Kulturlandschaft in Deutschland zu
erhalten ich danke Ihnen
die meisten Wölfe die in Deutschland
bekannt sind Leben in Brandenburg
Niedersachsen und Sachsen und der
nächste Redner kommt auch aus in
Niedersachsen a pardon noch nicht
lina-salze spricht zuerst für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr verehrte Damen
und Herren ich möchte mal mit guten
Nachrichten beginnen wir haben jetzt
hier alle viel Spaß gehabt ich möchte
mal mit einer Erfolgsgeschichte anfangen
der Wolf war in den fast 150 Jahren in
Deutschland ausgerottet heute wächst die
Population wieder und das ist eine gute
Nachricht angesichts der Tatsache dass
fast 7000 Tierarten hierzulande vom
Aussterben bedroht ist der Rück die
Rückkehr des Wolfes zeigt dass
europäische nationale Schutzmaßnahmen
der Wolf
sorgt natürlich aber auch gerade für
viel Aufregung in einigen Regionen
Deutschlands verursachen wolfsrisse
Schäden und sie beunruhigen anwohnende
was aber sie Liebe unionsfraktionen in
ihrem Antrag fordern das steht in keinem
Verhältnis zu dem was sie eigentlich
fordern wollen was auch in ihrem Titel
drinsteht nämlich eine ausgewogene
Balance ich zitiere zwischen dem Schutz
von Mensch und Tier sowie dem
Artenschutz gut gemeint ist eben nicht
gut gemacht wenn es nach ihnen ginge
sollten wir sogenannte wolfsfreie Zonen
schaffen die Entnahme einer
spezifizierten Anzahl von Wölfen
erlauben ein fairer Kompromiss zwischen
dem Schutz des Tieres und den Interessen
der Landwirtschaft ist es ein nicht es
ist ein Abschuss ohne Wenn und Aber was
sie hier fordern sonst nichts
und ich erinnere Sie gerne daran dass
wir hier in dem Haus gemeinsam spd-union
2019 des Bundesnaturschutzgesetz
geändert haben und wir genau das
hergestellt haben was sie jetzt
behaupten zu tun nämlich eine
ausgewogene Balance wir haben damals
sachlich und mit Verstand verhandelt den
Abschluss von Wölfen haben wir
erleichtert wenn die Tiere ernste
landwirtschaftliche Schäden verursachen
und wir haben zum ersten Mal sowohl die
Schäden in der Landwirtschaft als auch
Schäden bei hobbitierhalterinnen und
hobbytierhalter berücksichtigt
nach geltendem Recht kann bereits jetzt
im schlimmsten Fall ein ganzes
Wolfsrudel entnommen werden bis Schäden
ausbleihen wie Sie sehen wir legen viel
Wert auf die Sorgen der Landwirtschaft
wir machen aber auch solide Politik die
den EU-Richtlinien entspricht
die Gesetzesnovelle die wir gemeinsam
mit ihnen verabschiedet haben die gilt
selbstverständlich auch den Menschen der
Abschluss von Wölfen ist demnach möglich
wenn ein Wolf ein Menschen verletzt ihn
verfolgt oder sich ihm gegenüber
unprovoziert aggressiv zeigt mit diesen
Änderungen haben wir Sicherung
Sicherheit für alle geschaffen für die
Tiere für den Wolf und für den Menschen
wir haben diese Novelle 2019
verabschiedet jetzt muss sie evaluiert
werden wie die Umsetzung vor Ort
funktioniert zusammen mit den Ländern
der Landwirtschaft den Naturschutz der
Bevölkerung eine Novelle nach der
anderen vorzuschlagen ist dagegen
unnötige Aktionismus und keine seriöse
Politik sehr geehrte Damen und Herren im
Antrieb und jetzt
gehe ich noch Wolfes in Deutschland
unverzüglich zu definieren und jährlich
zu bewerten sein ich möchte gerne daran
erinnern dass Deutschland zu den Ländern
mit den detailliertesten und umfassenden
monitoringsstandards gehört nirgendwo in
Europa werden wolfspopulationen so
sorgfältig gezählt und überwacht
jährlich diese Daten werden jährlich von
den Ländern gesammelt in einem
aufwändigen Verfahren wissenschaftlich
ausgewertet es gibt hier keine
Geheimnisse und keine Unklarheiten
so wurden in Deutschland für das
Monitoring Jahr 2020
158 Rudels 27 wolfspaare 19 sesshafte
einzelwölfe und damit insgesamt 43
adulte Würfel gezählt zu keiner anderen
Art gibt es in Deutschland so viele
detaillierte Daten wie zum Wolf dass es
die Wahrheit
und sie schreiben weiter man sollte die
Kriterien für den Erhaltungszustand des
Wolfes offenlegen liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen das hat mich etwas verwundert
denn diese Informationen sind ebenfalls
alle öffentlich zugänglich es geht um
die Gesamtzahl der Population aber das
ist nicht das einzige Kriterium es geht
auch um die Verbreitung es geht um die
Größe und Qualität des Habitats und es
geht um die zukunftsaussichtung Aussicht
Aussichten von für die Entwicklung des
Wolfes es geht also um eine insgesamte
Verteilung und die um die genetische
Vielfalt der Population bei der
Bewertung wie es gut ist dem Wolf in
Deutschland geht
und es geht also um einen soliden
wissenschaftlichen
schutzansatz und nicht um Schlagzeilen
und auch wenn sich der deutsche
Wolfsbestand und ich glaube da sind wir
uns einig in den vergangenen Jahren
positiv entwickelt hat ist es Gesamtbild
dieser Kriterien immer noch nicht genug
um Wölfe einfach so abschießen zu können
auch wenn das hier von Ihnen gewünscht
wird sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nach
150 Jahren ohne Wolf kehrt dieses Tier
nun wieder in unsere Wälder zurück und
schließt damit eine Lücke in unserem
Ökosystem das ist eine gute Nachricht
und ich wünschte mir wir könnten solche
Erfolge für den Artenschutz jede
Sitzungswoche hier verkünden
diese Rückkehr bringt aber
selbstverständlich Herausforderung für
alle Mensch und Tier deshalb brauchen
wir ein gutes Monitoringsystem Maßnahmen
zum Herrn Schutz eine finanzielle
Kompensation für weidetierhalter eine
regelmäßige Überprüfung der aktuellen
Situation und ja auch in Einzelfällen
die Entnahme von Einzeltieren im Rahmen
der Möglichkeiten des
Bundesnaturschutzgesetzes und der
europäischen Regelung was wir definitiv
nicht brauchen sind populistische
Forderungen vielen Dank
sagt Lena Salz für die SPD-Fraktion und
ich hatte ja eben schon Frank Ring
angefangen anzukündigen weil er aus
Niedersachsen kommt wo eben auch Wölfe
leben und weil er auch ausgebildeter
Landwirt ist hier spricht er als
Mitglied der afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin Werte Kollegen heute
unterhalten wir uns zum zweiten Mal in
diesem Jahr über das leidige und einfach
zu lösende wolfsproblemen in Deutschland
die Wölfe erobern mittlerweile nicht nur
unsere ländlichen Räume sondern auch
unsere Städte wie beispielsweise die
niedersächsische Landeshauptstadt
Hannover und ihre Region auch ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin können sich
mittlerweile zu den Betroffenen Haltern
von getöteten Tieren zählen scheinbar
ist das in Verbindung mit der
niedersächsischen Landtagswahl nun
endlich grund genug dass auch die CDU
sich damit beschäftigt liebe Kollegen
von der CDU
liebe Kollegen von der CDU ich frage
mich warum sie vor wenigen Monaten
unseren Antrag abgelehnt haben und nun
weite Teile unsere Begründung und
unseres Antrags in ihrem übernommen
haben
lesen Sie mal ihre Begründung ab dem
dritten Satz haben sie abgeschrieben und
das kann man auch sehen ich habe da auch
sehr darüber gestaunt das mal zum einen
nun ist es ja nicht so dass nur sie
versprochen haben die Voice Probleme zu
regulieren auch die FDP hat das vor der
Bundestagswahl getan und meine Damen und
Herren heute Nachmittag saßen wir im
ausschusssaal des
landwirtschaftsunternährungsausschusses
und haben dort die Brüsseler Erklärung
entgegengenommen von einigen beide
Tierhaltern und zu meinem Erstaunen habe
ich festgestellt dass auch die SPD und
die Linke unbedingt die Wolfsbestände
regulieren wollen darum kann ich ja nur
sagen heute werden wir sicherlich alle
ihrem Antrag zustimmen und das wolf-
mittlerweile wissen wir dass es keine
wolfssicheren Zäune gibt wie uns Grünen
wolfsfreundlichen Ideologen Vereine und
Verbände weiß machen wollten genauso
wenig bewährt haben sich die
Herdenschutzhunde die im Grunde nicht
weniger gefährlich sind als die Wölfe
außerdem gefährdet natürlich stimmt das
außerdem gefährdet der Wolf den
Hochwasserschutz und den Tourismus
beispielsweise bei mir zu Hause in der
Lüneburger Heide die Zahl der von Wölfen
getöteten Nutztiere hat sich trotz aller
herdenschutzmaßnahmen innerhalb von nur
zwei Jahren fast verdoppelt meine Damen
und Herren 4000 wolfsrisse in den
letzten im letzten Jahr lässt die
Dimension dieser Tierquälerei deutlich
werden und wenn ich wenn ich sowas höre
wie er halt von atemvielfalt in meiner
Nachbarin in meinem Nachbarlandkreis in
der Göhrde hat der Wolf das Muffelwild
ausgerottet soviel dann zu dem
atemerhalt
trotzdem wurde bisher nicht reagiert um
die Schäden zu reduzieren und die
aktuelle steuermittelverschwendung für
herdenschutzpräventionsmaßnahmen von
ungefähr 10 Millionen Euro im Jahr nicht
noch weiter ausliefern zu lassen ist die
Entnahme der Wölfe unbedingt notwendig
Wölfe haben keine natürlichen Feinde
nach wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
würde eine Anzahl von ungefähr 1000
Tieren absolut ausreichen mehr als das
Doppelte an Wölfen schätzen auch die
geringsten Statistiken die es in unserem
Land gibt ich kann nur an ihren gesunden
Menschenverstand appellieren folgen wir
unseren schwedischen finnischen und
französischen Nachbarn und bejagen wir
die Wölfe um unsere weidetierhalter und
unsere Bevölkerung zu schützen vielen
Dank
Frank Rink war das für die afd-fraktion
nächster Redner ist Harald Ebner von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen erste Vorsitzende
des Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
Notwehr Sicherheit und Verbraucherschutz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stecken in
der größten im größten Artensterben seit
Menschen gedenken die Wissenschaft Wand
von einem Point of no Return und die
Union will Wölfe abschießen und um das
zu kaschieren was sie da in Wahrheit
wollen nämlich den Wolf wieder
auszurotten reden sie im Titel ihres
Antrags reden sie im Titel ihres Antrags
nicht nur von einer Balance sondern von
einer
ausgewogenen hören Sie doch mal zu
sondern von einer ausgewogenen Balance
also ich weiß ich habe jetzt lange mal
nachgedacht ich bin nicht drauf gekommen
was eine nicht ausgewogene Balance wäre
also da wäre vielleicht eine Beratung
durch das Institut für deutsche Sprache
gar nicht schlecht gewesen aber nicht
mal nicht mal die Überschrift Ihres
Antrags ergibt sinnlebe Union genauso
wenig der Inhalt hier geht der blanke
Populismus mit Ihnen durch wer in ihrem
Text nach Hilfen für den Herdenschutz
sucht der sucht sich einen Wolf aber
genau die brauchen wir doch für die
weidetierhalter und die werden wir auch
auf den Weg bringen stattdessen schüren
sie Ängste Kollege Mack mit Rotkäppchen
sie zwischen Scheinlösungen auf und
[Musik]
liefern keine konstruktiven Beiträge
unser wissenschaftlich vorbildliches
bestandsmonitoring das passt ihnen nicht
weil sie lieber mit aufgeblähten
Bestandszahlen Panik verbreiten wollen
sie fordern sie fordern was Gutes sie
fordern die Erfassung von von
riss-schäden und Kosten für den
Herdenschutz wunderbar das ist schön
aber das gibt es doch schon das gibt es
doch schon also vielleicht sollen sie
sich einfach mal die Berichte durchlesen
also das ist ja schön da müssen sie mit
ihren Anträgen früher aufstehen und ihr
ewiges Mantra der Wolf ins Jagdrecht das
wird euch durch ständige Wiederholung
nicht praktikabler sondern das erschwert
durch durch kompetenzwirr war schnelle
Entnahmen und unsere Jäger die haben
doch wahrhaft besseres zu tun als von
ihnen noch den Abschluss von Wölfen
übergeholfen zu bekommen ich bin froh
wenn sie die Wildbestände so regulieren
können dass unser Wald vernünftig
aufwachsen kann
sie berufen sich mit ihren wolfsfreien
Zonen und bestandsregulierungen auf
Schweden was passiert denn in Schweden
die klein gehaltene Population ist durch
Inzucht gefährdet und genau deshalb sage
ich was sie da wollen ist eine
Ausrottung weil eine durch Inzucht
gefährdete Population ist oft dauert
nicht lebensfähig und außerdem hilft es
auch nicht sie kriegen doch die
ziehenden Jungwölfe gar nicht aus der
Welt und das was sie versprechen
funktioniert deshalb nur wenn sie den
Wolf flächendeckend wieder ausrotten und
es wird Artenschutz in ihrem Antrag des
schämt sich ja fast schon selber und ja
ich wünsche mir von ihnen tatsächlich
mal eine konstruktive Oppositionsarbeit
statt einem Balanceakt wie es ihn
eigentlich Versprechen in ihrer
Überschrift haben sie leider schon
wieder das Gleichgewicht verloren danke
schön
Harald Ebner war das krieg hier noch
einige Mitteilungen mit auf dem Weg
allerdings eher auf der Rednerliste
steht nun Ina lattendorf von der
Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin verehrte Kollegen und
Kollegen der Wolf hat Deutschland ist in
Deutschland wieder zurück hat in die
Natur gefunden aber es läuft nicht alles
glatt der Antrags in der Unionsfraktion
trägt in Teilen den agrarpolitischen
Problematiken durchaus Rechnung das
Problem ist sie greifen in ihren
Schlussfolgerungen aber meiner Meinung
nach bisher fehlenden aber notwendigen
Daten vor wir haben leider faktisch
keine verlässlichen bundesweiten Daten
auch wenn wir hier gerade was anderes
gehört haben und Sie haben recht wenn
sie ein Monitoring und ein aktives
Bestandsmanagement fordern und dem
stimmen wir linken zu
denn ob man in Deutschland von einem
günstigen Erhaltungszustand des Wolfes
ausgehen kann wie sie allerdings
unterstellen ist umstritten das
Bundesministerium
Bundesumweltministerium zum Beispiel
sieht Wolfsbestände noch weit entfernt
von einem günstigen Erhaltungszustand
die deutschen Schafhalter auch heute
hier im Saal sehen diesen Zustand
natürlich als erreicht an angesichts der
risszahlen die Sie zu verzeichnen haben
und das Problem ist dass bislang jedes
Bundesland für sich das Wolfsmonitoring
eigenständig betreibt in meinem
Bundesland Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gehen
die Fachleute stand 21 von 14
Wolfsrudeln aus ist das zu viel was ist
der Maßstab klare und aktuelle Aussagen
zum Erhaltungszustand insgesamt
bundesweit fehlen und da ist definitiv
nachzubessern
liebe Kollegen aus der Union wenn Sie
nun fordern das Bundesjagdgesetz zu
ändern und den Wolf in den Katalog der
jagdbaren Arten aufzunehmen ist das
populistisch als wenn es so einfach wäre
in ihre Forderung den Wolf vom Anhang 4
in Anhang fünf der FFH-Richtlinie neu
einzustehen einzustufen sehe ich eine
ziemlich schräge Gleichstellung mit
Baummarder und Iltis und das wie gesagt
ohne belastbare Datengrundlage mit ihren
Forderungen tun sie den zweiten Schritt
vor den ersten lassen Sie uns den ersten
tun denn es geht auch darum zwischen
Naturerhaltung Nachhaltigkeit und
Wirtschaftlichkeit eine ausgewogene
Balance herzustellen das ist ja auch in
ihrem Wortlaut aber dazu reicht es nicht
einfach Wölfe abschießen zu lassen und
dann die weidetierhalter trotzdem im
Regen stehen zu lassen denn wenn Sie
etwas für die Weidehaltung tun wollen
dann folgen Sie unserer jahrelangen
Forderung helfen Sie mit einen
verlässlichen bundesweit einheitlichen
Rechtsanspruch auf Erstattung aller
Aufwendungen für den Herdenschutz
inklusive der abgel der verbundenen
Arbeitszeit zu garantieren zweitens
realisieren sie dass die soziale
Absicherung der weidetierhalter jeder
Beschreibung spottet denn auch ganz ohne
Wolf geht es den Schäfern nicht
besonders gut Selbstausbeutung ist an
der Tagesordnung Stundenlöhne von sechs
Euro sind keine Ausnahme und das bei
einem Arbeitsalltag von zwölf Stunden
und länger ohne Wochenende und ohne
geregelten Urlaub wir fordern eine
soziale Absicherung die dem Engagement
auch dieser Berufsgruppe gerecht wird
die Regierung muss endlich in der
weidetierhaltung für soziale und
ökologische Gerechtigkeit sorgen und das
sage ich klar mit Blick auf dem die
Fehlstellen im aktuellen
Haushaltsentwurf denn nämlich dann
nämlich wird der Wolf auch dort als eine
Tatsache für viele erträgliche wenn der
soziale Ausgleich erfolgt und das sollte
doch unser Ziel sein
sagt Ina lattendorf die Population der
Wölfe wächst seit Jahren momentan soll
es 157
Wolfsrudel geben allerdings gehören zu
so einem Rudel immer fünf bis zehn Tiere
das ist dann gar nicht so einfach die
Gesamtzahl anzugeben Ulrike Harzer
spricht jetzt für die FDP-Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Thema das uns
vorliegenden Antrages der cdu/csu ist
insbesondere die Problematik der
zunehmenden Wolfspopulation in
Deutschland
diese geschiedenen Zahlen sind aus
artenschutzrechtlicher Sicht aufgrund
der gewünschten wieder anzieht
Ansiedlung ein voller Erfolg
die wachsende Menge an Wölfen
insbesondere in einigen der wolfsreichen
Regionen Deutschlands entwickelt sich
jedoch inzwischen zu einer zunehmenden
Herausforderung für den Menschen und
hierbei besonders für die
weidetierhaltung
trotz umfangreicher Präventionsmaßnahmen
wie Zäune herdschutzhunde steigen die
Probleme für die Weite Tierhalter
wolfsrisse von Weidetieren wie Schafen
Rindern Pferden neben signifikant zu
die Union bemängelt nun in ihrem Antrag
wie so oft in letzter Zeit Zustände und
gesetzliche Regelungen zu deren Klärung
und Umsetzung sich selbst ausreichend
Zeit hatten und deren unzureichende
Erfüllung sie selbst zu verantworten
haben
das betrifft sowohl das Wolfsmonitoring
zur Beobachtung der Bestandsentwicklung
des Wolfes als auch das Wolfsmanagement
selbst
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
dennoch sind in dem Antrag einige
wichtige Punkte enthalten auch wir
wollen das Zusammenleben von weitetieren
Mensch und Wolf gut und mit möglichst
wenigen Konflikten gestalten gerade der
angestrebte Anstieg von Weite
Tierhaltung in der Natur statt im Stall
und der Städte Zuwachs des
wolfsbestandes erhöhen die Spannung und
die Konflikte
dem Schutz von Wölfen weite Tieren und
den menschlichen Bedürfnissen muss aus
diesem Grunde gleichermaßen Rechnung
getragen werden und zur Wahrheit gehört
eben auch bessere Kriterien für die
Möglichkeit zur Entnahme von Wölfen zu
schaffen
bereits im Koalitionsvertrag der letzten
Wahlperiode hatten sie sich liebe
Kollegen von der Union ähnliche Ziele
selbst schon vorgenommen und haben in
vier Jahren keine ausreichende Lösung
herbeigeführt
die 2020 erfolgte Änderungen war nicht
weitreichend genug sie haben solch ein
regionales Bestandsmanagement zwar
mehrfach diskutiert in ihre Fraktion wie
zum Beispiel in ihre Pressemitteilung
von 2019 ersichtlich ist aber diese
nicht eingeführt hätten sie dies getan
und ihre Vorgaben tatsächlich umgesetzt
während die Kleinen Anfragen von ihnen
zu Beginn der neuen Legislatur zu diesem
Thema überflüssig gewesen
entweder
waren sie nicht willens genug oder der
Weg zur Problemlösung ist dann doch
komplexer und langwieriger in beiden
Fällen ist ihre Kritik an der Ampel für
ihre eigenen Versäumnisse unangemessen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die Ampeln
hat sich im Koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen die Monitoring Standards zu
überarbeiten um den Wolfsbestand in
Deutschland
realitätstreugetreu abbilden zu können
darüber hinaus werden wir den Ländern
ein regionaldifferenziertes
Bestandsmanagement ermöglichen wichtig
ist hier jedoch wohl überlegt diese
Maßnahmen umzusetzen denn sie müssen im
Einklang mit den schwierigen
Rahmenbedingungen des europäischen
Rechts stehen um für alle Beteiligten
rechtssichere Verhältnisse zu schaffen
Schnellschüsse helfen uns hier nicht
weiter
als Ampel werden wir uns jedoch dieses
Thema es annehmen und deshalb ihren
Antrag für die weitere Arbeit in den
Ausschuss vorweisen und freuen uns auf
Ihre Mitarbeiter vielen Dank
so jetzt gab es schon eine ganze Menge
Zwischenrufe von dem Herrn Otto jetzt
darf er richtig mal hier vom Mikrofon
sprechen für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vielen
Dank für die Begrüßung ich meine es sehr
ernst und die Lage in unserer Region ist
tot ernst und wird hier in Teilen der
Lage nicht angemessen und der Hocker was
haben Sie damals für den Wahlkampf
gemacht ich wünsche Ihnen nur dass sie
diesen Elan den sie damals vor der Wahl
hatten auch gegenüber ihrem
Koalitionspartner zum Ausdruck bringen
denn ich will ihnen eins sagen
versetzen Sie sich mal bitte in die Lage
der Schafhalter vor Ort in 13 Angriffen
79 tote Tiere und noch viele die bei
lebendigen Leibe dort liegen und
vegetieren und der Ebner ich hätte mir
bei ihrer Rede einmal Konstrukt Herr
Ebner
ich hätte mir bei ihrer
dann spreche ich halt nicht zu ihnen
sondern zum Haus ich hätte mir von Herrn
Ebner mal konstruktive Vorschläge
vorgestellt und was ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe dass die zuständigen Minister
für Landwirtschaft und für Umwelt heute
nicht da sind was ist denn das für ein
Umgehen mit der Situation vor Ort
dieses Bild was ich ihnen schildere ist
tagtäglich bei mir im Wahlkreis bei uns
in der Lüneburger Heide in dem
wolfsverdichteten Gebiet der Welt
tagtäglich zu sehen hier werden die
letzten Weidetiere verschwinden das
letzte Rotwild kommt unter Druck aber
vor allem die scharfalter werden
aufgeben und da ist es eben nicht mit
Erstattungen getan sondern der Stress
der tägliche die viele Arbeit die Sorgen
die Fürsorge um die Tiere die scharfheit
der leben von und mit den Tieren sie
werden dem nicht gerecht wir müssen hier
den Zustand ändern meine Damen und
Herren und da haben sie die Regierung
Tiere im Wald Tiere auf der Heide
Schäfer auf der Heide alles ist dann weg
wenn wir so weitermachen jetzt muss
gehandelt werden es ist genug evaluiert
worden die Zahlen sind da der günstige
Erhaltungszustand ist längst gegeben und
das müssen sie nach Brüssel melden damit
die Tiere in den anderen fünf kommen und
man hier in Berlin Möglichkeiten hat die
Gesetze anzupassen meine Damen und
Herren
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Herr
geschätzter Kollege Otte
sie sprachen gerade in ihrer Rede davon
das Rotwild sei durch den Wolf bereits
in Bedrängnis geraten
wie Sie vielleicht wissen sind unsere
Anstrengungen groß in Zeiten des
Klimawandels die Natur für Jungen die
nächste Waldgeneration irgendwie hoch zu
bekommen und die hohen wilddichten in
Deutschland tragen ihren Teil dazu bei
dass dieser Erfolg diese harte Arbeit
vieler försterinnen und Förster nur
schwer gelingt und deswegen möchte ich
ich sie fragen ob sie von diesem Problem
der hohen wilddichten wissen und ob sie
davon wissen dass der Wolf hier
natürlich auch ein Beitrag wieder
leisten könnte um in ein natürliches
Gleichgewicht zu kommen das heute so
nicht vorhanden ist und das heute
erfolgreichen Waldumbau fit für die
Zukunft nur sehr schwer möglich macht
sehr geschätzter Kollege da fragen Sie
genau den richtigen ich habe viele
Pflanzen selbst gesetzt im Wald ich bin
selbst Jäger ich komme aus der
Lüneburger Heide und ich lade sie ganz
ganz herzlich mal ein nicht nur unsere
Truppenübungsplätze zu besuchen sondern
auch die Gebiete wo die Förster sind
aber wo auch die privaten Waldbauer sind
das Rotwild kommt dermaßen unter Druck
und wird auch bei lebendigem Leibe
aufgefressen und sie haben auch
Verantwortung für Flora und Fauna meine
Damen und Herren und deswegen sage ich
erst wenn das letzte weidetier
verschwunden ist dann brauchen Sie
keinen günstigen haltungszustand mehr zu
melden jetzt haben sie die Verantwortung
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben eine völlige überkonzentration
wir haben von Wölfen und das
Rudelverhalten des Rotwildes ist so dass
sie sich zusammenführen wie Wagenburgen
und ich lade auch sie einzukommen öffnen
sie endlich mal die Augen haben sie mal
Verständnis für die schaffhalterfamilien
wenn die bei lebendigen Leibe sehen wie
ihre Tiere zugrunde gehen meine Damen
und Herren es liegt daran dass wir eine
überkonzentration haben der günstige
Erhaltungszustand ist längs gegeben das
muss nach Brüssel gemeldet werden damit
wir hier in Deutschland Maßnahmen
durchführen können und ich lade die
Umweltministerin der Staatssekretär sehr
herzlich ein beizukommen mit den
scharfheitern mal zu sprechen und nicht
hier uns Populismus vorzuwerfen keiner
ihrer Rednerinnen und Redner hat mal
gesagt was sie machen würden wenn sie
scharfalter werden sie haben nur uns
Populismus vorgeworfen wir setzen uns
ein für die Menschen für die Tiere und
wir fordern sie auf machen sie endlich
von ihrer Verantwortung gebraucht melden
sie endlich die Zahlen die da sind nach
Brüssel der günstige Erhaltungszustand
Herr Ebner der ist längst erreicht beim
Wolf es muss jetzt gehandelt werden wir
bitten Sie herzlich darum
ich möchte nur bemerken zwischen Fragen
lasse ich natürlich in der Regel schon
zu aber ich unterbreche auch ungern dann
im Fluss deswegen also wenn die Redner
mir ab und zu eine Chance geben würden
dann auch vielleicht dazu wenn sie es
gar nicht wollen ist es natürlich auch
was anderes ja das hier war eine
Erklärung weil Ralf lenkert aus der
Linksfraktion sich gemeldet hatte aber
eben nicht zum Zuge kam mit einer
Zwischenfrage sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr
Staatssekretär und sehr geehrte Frau
Staatssekretärin sie sind natürlich hier
weil sie dieses Thema auch wichtig
finden
ich möchte einmal was sagen zu meinen
Orte das war viel Meinung wenig Ahnung
alles gut ich fand also schon sehr
interessant dass sie ihren den Antrag
schon einmal noch umgeändert haben den
Titel ursprünglich war es
weitestyhaltung durch nachhaltiges
wolfsbestandsmanagement zu ermöglichen
da konnte ich so ein bisschen
nachvollziehen was sie wollen mit dem
jetzigen Titel wollen Sie den Wolf
abschießen das Problem ist einfach
dadurch nicht gelöst wenn sie das nur
damit machen wollen und keinen
Herdenschutz machen dann müssen sie alle
Wölfe abschießen und das schaffen sie
gar nicht mehr
außerdem gibt es eine Reihe von
Einrichtungen die sich intensiv mit
Wolfsmonitoring und Management
beschäftigen es gibt die Dokumentation
und Beratungsstelle des Bundes in
Görlitz und des Bundeszentrum weidet
hier und Wolf der Bundesanstalt für
Ernährung in Eberswalde unser Ziel auf
Bundesebene sollte sein die wirklich die
dauerhaft erforderliche und personell
gut auszustatten damit sie ihre
Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben wirklich
nachkommen können es gibt auch viele
regionale Institutionen nicht zuletzt
ist wolfskompetenzzentrum meines
Heimatlandes Sachsen-Anhalt denn die
Rückkehr der Wolke erfordert einfach
auch eine präventive Anpassung der
weidetierhaltung
hier ist die Initiative der Tierhalter
unverzichtbar um durch die Wölfe
verursachte Schäden zu vermeiden bzw zu
minimieren Wölfe sind sehr lernfähig und
bei mangelhaftem oder
fehlenden Präventionsmaßnahmen können
wiederholt Übergriffe eine Herde
wirklich gefährden Vorbeugung ist die
beste schadensverordnungverhütung
beide Tiere sind essentiell für den
Erhalt der Kulturlandschaft wir nehmen
daher die berechtigten Sorgen der
weidetierhalter sehr ernst und natürlich
muss ihnen eine wirtschaftliche Zukunft
ermöglicht werden und das kann nur mit
effektiven Herdenschutz funktionieren
das beginnt mit einer individuellen
Beratung denn man kann das Geld nur
sinnvoll verwenden wenn man weiß wie man
es anstellt und hier ist im Einzelfall
die Maßnahmen müssen genau abgestimmt
werden insbesondere der technische
Herdenschutz ist zu nennen es können
feste oder mobile Zäune sein in
Kombination mit elektrischen Weidezaun
Geräten
die Anschaffung wird finanziell
unterstützt und die Einhaltung von den
mindeststandsstats bei Zaunhöhe und
Beschaffenheit ist in den ist eine
Voraussetzung für
Entschädigungszahlungen der richtige
Zaun mit der notwendigen Spannung
gewährleistet nach Aussage von Experten
ungefähr 80 Prozent der gesamten
Schutzwirkung durch geeignete
Herdenschutzhunde können Sie das eben
noch mal um 15 Prozent erhöhen ein
Restrisiko ist sicherlich nicht
auszuschließen aber ich habe lange
Erfahrungen in Sachsen-Anhalt und bin
wirklich ein zwanzig Zaun mit
vernünftiger Spannung war haben in
diesen zwei Jahren keine Verluste an
Weidetieren waren
beklagen
so wir haben also das in der IG
Herdenschutz plus Hund mit wirklich
Leuten das ist ein Schäfermeister der
ist in Sachsen-Anhalt organisiert und er
sagt er hat keinen weidetheater den er
beraten hat und der seinen ganzen
Beratungen folgt bisher mit Problemen in
seiner weidetierhaltung festgestellt ich
würde Sie einladen nach Sachsen-Anhalt
kommen sie wir können das zusammen uns
mal anschauen
schauen wir uns die Ergebnisse der
herrenschussmaßnahmen in Sachsen-Anhalt
an während im Monitoring Jahr 1920 erst
385 Nutztiere bei 95 wolfsübergriffen
erwischt hat wann es 2021 nur noch 233
Tiere bei 62 Übergriffen und das bei
einer steigenden rudelzahl so sieht
erfolgreiches Wolfsmanagement aus
Frau Kollegin erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
[Musik]
Herdenschutz und die Umsetzung der
artenschutzrechtlichen Regelungen sind
vor allem Ländersache der Bund
unterstützt die Länder dabei tragbare
und sachgerechte Lösungen für
präventiven Herdenschutz zu finanzieren
das erklärte Ziel im Koalitionsvertrag
ist es den Erfahrungsaustausch zu
bündeln daher arbeiten wir gerade an der
Einrichtung eines Dialogs weitet
Tierhaltung und Wolf die sich mit diesen
Fragen befassen
befassten Organisationen und Verbände
werden daran teilnehmen ohne die
Zuständigkeit für die rüstbegutachtung
von Landesbehörden direkt wahrgenommen
werden sollte wie sie es in ihrem Antrag
formulieren würden wir auch dort beraten
in Gebirgslagen und ein Deichen ist der
Herdenschutz eine besondere
Herausforderung es liegt daran dass es
sich oft um unwegsames und
unübersichtliches Gelände handelt oder
aber Vorgaben des Hochwasserschutzes zu
beachten sind was wir nicht machen
können ist die Einrichtung wolfsfreier
Zonen wie sie es in ihrem Antrag
formulieren das haben wir nämlich
festgestellt dass es eu-rechtswidrig
wäre und wie der EuGH in seinem Urteil
vom 10 Oktober 2019 ist auch schon mal
bestätigt hat der Herr Auernhammer hat
eine Rückfrage
also okay es gibt sind noch fünf
Sekunden
aber bitteschön
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und Frau Dr
Kirsten dass sie die tütenfrage zulassen
sie haben uns jetzt sehr viel erzählt
von den zaunmaßnahmen von den soundungen
abgesehen davon dass diese Zone in der
Auslegung dann verdammt schwer sind dass
unsere Schäfer hier sehr viel zu
schleppen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
haben möchte ich Sie fragen wie stellen
Sie sich vor wie man diese Zäune am
hochfellen am hochriss in den Bergen
aufstellen soll oder an den Teichen wie
stellen Sie sich vor dass man hier einen
wolfssicheren Zaun über die Berge weiß
nicht ob sie den jubiläumsgrad kennen ob
sie diese Bergregionen kennen wie
stellen Sie sich vor dass man hier
wolfssichere Zäune aufstellen kann und
da ich überweist dass sie gleich mit den
Argumenten der Herdenschutzhunde kommen
wir haben hier wunderbare Wandergebiete
hier ist der Tourismus auch eine
Einkommenssituation eine
Einkommensquelle für die ganzen Täler
wie wollen Sie sicherstellen dass diese
Herdenschutz die Touristen auch wenn sie
aus Sachsen-Anhalt kommen nicht
angreifen danke schön
kann sich 21 gemeinsam mit uns
einschließungsantrag geschlossen haben
die Forschung zu effektiven Herdenschutz
in diesen besonderen Gebieten zu
unterstützen und aktuell läuft genau
dieses forschungsforschungsprojekt an
der Hochschule für Wirtschaft und Umwelt
Nürtingen Geislingen und wir sind sicher
gut beraten uns die Ergebnisse dieser
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung
anzuschauen um danach zu entscheiden wie
wir damit weiter vorgehen
außerdem möchte ich gerne betonen dass
das Land Niedersachsen aus Landesmitteln
Forschung zu besserem herrenschutz auch
an Deichen fördert dort werden
Umweltschutz und Landwirtschaft eben
immer schon zu zusammen gedacht und mein
Dank geht daher an den Minister Olaf
Lies
wenn es trotz Herdenschutz zu nutzen
durch Wölfe kommt werden diese
selbstverständlich entschädigt und ich
bin schon noch einmal Prävention durch
Herdenschutz ist der beste und
eigentlich der einzige Weg vielen Dank
und das Wort geht noch mal an die
cdu/csu-fraktionen Alexander radwahn
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich spreche jetzt hier nicht
weil ich den zuständigen Ausschüssen bin
sondern weil ich wie der Kollege Otte
als lokaler Abgeordneter mit dem Thema
konfrontiert bin aber jetzt weniger im
Norden sondern im Süden dort wo die
Almen zu Hause sind und dort ist schon
seit sehr sehr langer Zeit des Wolf ein
großes Thema
und dort haben die Bauern schlicht und
ergreifendes Gefühl dass Teile der
deutschen Politik der Wolf wichtiger ist
als ihre Höfe als die Almen als der halt
Erhalt der kleinen Landwirtschaft meine
Damen und Herren
und das betrifft uns in Bayern bei den
Almen bei den Alpen aber auch in Tirol
und die Meldung die ich die Tage
bekommen habe ist aus Tirol 300 Tiere
gerissen über 1500 Tiere frühzeitig
abgetrieben weil es die Bauern satt
haben und ihre Tiere nicht mehr sicher
sind tun sie diese runter für meine
Damen und Herren
unsere Bauern gerade die allen Bauern
arbeiten mit sehr viel Idealismus mit
sehr viel Leidenschaft auf ihren Almen
setzen sich dort eines ist sehr
arbeitsinsiv und viele profitieren davon
Ausflügler wandra Mountainbiker ist
möchte ich das zu Ende führen einfach
mal habe eh nur drei Minuten wollen das
zu Ende führen besten Dank und viele
profitieren davon
und dann ist es umso erstaunlicher wenn
bestimmt die Ziele die immer hoch
gehalten werden wie Tierschutz wie
Anbindehaltung soll verhindert werden
und so weiter konterkariert werden weil
ein natürlicheres Leben wie auf der Alm
gibt es für die Tiere nicht was ist
Ihnen da wichtiger wollen Sie dass die
Stück für Stück aufhören und dieses
entsprechend nach dem was bleibt
eigentlich mit der Artenvielfalt wenn in
kürzester Zeit die Almen wieder
versteppen und es zurückgeht meine Damen
und Herren da sind sie selber nicht
konsistent in ihrer Argumente ihnen ist
der Wolf wichtiger als all die anderen
Argumente diese regelmäßig anführen und
der Höhepunkt war vor einem Jahr da
haben die Bauern sich die Mühe gemacht
mal so einen Zaun hinzustellen und da
war dann der Vertreter des BUND
Naturschutzes und der hat bei seinem
Grundwort gesagt ich bin dafür dass es
Bauern allen Bauern und Wolf eine
Koexistenz gibt wenn dieses aber nicht
möglich ist da müssen die allen Bauern
die seit Jahr sollten ihre Almen haben
eben ihren Betrieb einstellen das sagt
dieser Mann diesen Menschen ins Gesicht
die alles daran setzen unsere
Kulturlandschaft entsprechend zu
erhalten meine Damen und Herren in
manchen Regionen ist eine Koexistenz
nicht möglich da darf man nicht nur
träumen sondern da muss man die Realität
ins Gesicht schauen man muss diese
Menschen in ihren Sorgen ernst nehmen
und schauen dass die Almwirtschaft dort
vorangeht und nicht nur in Sonntagsreden
oder bei allen Begehungen entsprechend
das große Lied singen und am Schluss die
Menschen allein lassen besten Dank meine
Damen und Herren
fragt sie uns über die Reifen und
Applaus für Alexander Radwan hier haben
auch doch durchaus einige
afd-abgeordnete applaudiert und
natürlich seine eigene Fraktion die
Union jetzt gibt es eine
kurzintervektion von Ralf lenkert aus
der Linksfraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Kollege radwahn
sind ihnen die Zahlen bekannt dass es im
Jahre 2005 in Deutschland
2,64 Millionen Schafe gab im Jahre 2013
also fast noch keine Wolfsbestände gab
war die Zahl auf 1,5 Millionen Schafe
gesunken um diese Zahl pegelt sie sich
bis heute ein die Ursache ist die
unzureichende Finanzierung der
weidetierhaltung und meine Kollegin
ehemal Kollegen Kirstin Tackmann hat sie
jedes Jahr darauf hingewiesen dass wir
dringend eine weidetierprämie brauchen
um eben die weidetierhalter die
Schäferin und Schäfer und auch ihre
Almbauern zu unterstützen damit sie eben
die Kulturlandschaft behalten können sie
haben dies jedes Mal verhindert
ich möchte Sie darauf hinweisen
dass wir auch dieses Jahr wieder 50
Millionen Euro extra fordern für eine
weidetier Prämie für die Weidehaltung
damit eben die Weite Tierhalter die
Schäferinnen und Schäfer mit die eine
Chance haben zu überleben was haben sie
gefordert sie fordern Wolf abschießen
das ist alles was sie kennen das ist
doch billig und ein nächster Punkt wir
haben jahrelang meine Kollegin Kirsten
Tackmann hat das jedes Mal gefordert
endlich mehr weideschutzmaßnahmen zu
finanzieren beide Schutzhunde zu
finanzieren weil ein herdenschutzzentrum
richtig aufzubauen sie haben dies
verhindert und jetzt einfach die Wölfe
abschießen wollen ist der falsche und
selbst wenn jeder Wolf getötet werden
wird Liebe Schäferin und Schäfer wird
ihre Existenz trotzdem nicht besser weil
sie eben die weidetierhaltung nicht gut
finanziert bekommen weil sie nicht
genügend Geld verdienen können ohne eine
Weile tierprämie werden Sie nicht
überleben können ob mit Wolf oder ohne
Wolf und deswegen fordern wir eine
weidetierprämie
wollen sie erwidern ja bitteschön
ich gefragt ob ich die Zahlen kenne ich
kann Ihnen sagen was bei mir in diesem
Sommer in den Alpen passiert ist und was
mir die bauen erzählt haben das kann ich
Ihnen erzählen und da können sie gerne
mal rauskommen und sich die bauen
entsprechend anhören wenn bei Ihnen und
bei mir geht es nicht primär am Schafe
sondern auch um die Kuhhaltung und die
Tiere dort wenn die dann über die Klippe
abstürzen können Sie gerne vorbeikommen
und sich das entsprechend anschauen und
ich halte es und das abschließend für
einen blanken Zynismus die Bauern fragen
mich nicht nach Geld oder irgendwelche
entsprechenden Zahlungen dafür sie
wollen in Ruhe sicher für ihre Tiere
sorgen und nicht zusehen wie sie
verenden müssen das ist purer Zionismus
was sie hier sagen dass die dazu schauen
müssen
soweit hier eine kurze Intervention und
dann die wiederum und damit kommen wir
zur letzten Rednerin in dieser Debatte
Zoe Meier spricht jetzt für Bündnis 90
die Grünen im Bundestag
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen es
ist ja schon ein bisschen absurd die
Menschheit die weiß wie man zum Mond
fliegt aber beim Punkt Weide Tierschutz
oder weidet hier Haltung der fällt der
Union wirklich gar nichts anderes ein
außer abschießen und das ist wirklich
sehr sehr traurig bei so einer Debatte
die beide Tierhaltung ist ein großer
Fortschritt für den Tierschutz weil
natürlich ist die weidetierhaltung
besser als alles was die
stealthierhaltung zu bieten hat und die
weidetierhaltung hat noch andere
positive Aspekte auf unsere Umwelt zum
Beispiel beim Landschaftsschutz oder
beim Humusaufbau und deswegen müssen wir
die beide Tierhaltung politisch
natürlich unterstützen
wir haben eindeutig auch Probleme mit
wolfsrissen und wir erkennen das an und
genau deswegen beschäftigen wir uns auch
damit ernsthafte Maßnahmen zu finden und
fordern nicht einfach wildpopulistisch
den Wolf abschießen wir wissen dass es
das Problem nicht lösen wird wir haben
schon einige Punkte heute zum Thema
Herdenschutz angesprochen und auch meine
Kollegin Franziska Kersten hat ja
bereits darauf hingewiesen wir haben
eine tolle Dokumentation darüber was
hilft und was können wir eigentlich tun
beim Herdenschutz und wir sehen auch in
über 80 Prozent der Fällen wo es
wolfstische Gas geschaffen und Ziegen da
gab es keinen hinreichenden Herdenschutz
oder sogar gar keinen Herdenschutz und
da müssen wir ansetzen da müssen wir
auch von unseren Nachbarin Ländern
lernen die ja schon länger auch den Wolf
beheimaten
Frau Kollegin erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage
tatsächlicher dazu schon alles gesagt
mir ist es wichtig noch mal darauf
hinzuweisen wir haben in den Ländern
auch schon Förderprogramme fast alle
Bundesländer bieten das an und auch der
Bund unterstützt ja mit Fördermitteln
über die gab und über die GAG also es
passiert viel und wir sind natürlich
bereit fortwährend auch unser
Instrumentarium weiterzuentwickeln und
da könnten sie sich auch mal konstruktiv
einbringen das glaube ich wollen sie
aber gar nicht an der Stelle und alle
die heute den Abschuss des Wolfes
fordern die sollen uns doch bitte einmal
nachweisen die sollen uns einmal
nachweisen dass das Abschießen wirklich
eine wirksame und vor allen Dingen eine
gerechtfertigtere Maßnahme für den
Tierschutz und für den Artenschutz ist
als die anderen Maßnahmen die wir haben
das tun sie nicht und ich bin mir sicher
sie können es auch nicht
zum Abschluss fährt Debatte muss man
natürlich sagen und gerade weil die
cdu/csu heute so viel über Tierschutz
gesprochen hat es ist natürlich die
traurige Ironie heute dass wenn der Wolf
am Ende die Weidetiere nicht tötet der
Mensch tut es ganz sicher und deswegen
ist der beste Tierschutz natürlich gar
nicht zu töten vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für eine Kurzintervention erhält die
Kollegin Damerow das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin sie haben
sehr viel gesprochen von
weidetierschutz von zaunschutz und so
weiter nun mein Wahlkreis ist das
nördliche Nord ist das Nordfriesland ist
Nordfriesland und es nördliche
Dithmarschen hinter den Deichen wie Sie
vielleicht wissen ist beide können Sie
ein bisschen näher ans bis beide
ist Zaunbau auf den Deichen nicht zu
verwirklichen auf der anderen Seite ist
scharfhaltung auf unseren Deichen
unverzichtbar um die den Deichbau
überhaupt erst nur sicher zu machen
jetzt frage ich sie wie soll denn in
einer Region wieder meinen ein weiter
ein ein weidetierschutz in dem man eben
nicht Zäunen kann funktionieren übrigens
das ähnliche Problem wie auf den Almen
da haben sie keine Antworten drauf
dieses Thema diskutieren wir mit
diskutieren wir wirklich schon sehr
lange und das treibt die Schafhalter in
meiner Region um da ist nämlich Ende mit
wir ziehen Zäune geht nicht und
Hundehaltung Hütehunde geht ebenfalls
nicht was schlagen Sie diesen Menschen
vor sind sie wenigstens bereit sich
darüber Gedanken zu machen dass wir in
Deutschland auch Regionen brauchen in
denen es den Wolf nicht gibt
Frau Kollegin Meyer und sehr wieder
ja sie sprechen natürlich an wir hätten
uns nicht mit Maßnahmen befasst ich
finde es einfach sehr sehr traurig wie
gesagt dass die Union nichts anderes zu
bieten hat außer abschießen da sind wir
uns ja alle einig wie sie auch schon
artenschutzrechtlich heute einmal
ausführlich begründet bekommen haben das
geht auch nicht wir haben einige
Möglichkeiten für den Herdenschutz wie
gesagt Frau Dr Kersten hat das schon
einiges aufgezählt ich möchte nicht die
Redundanz in die Debatte reinbringen
immer wieder die gleichen Argumente zu
wiederholen aber sie sind sehr herzlich
eingeladen sich konstruktiv bei uns an
dieser Debatte zu beteiligen wenn der
einzige Vorschlag immer wieder ist
abschießen dann ist das leider nicht
konstruktiv vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache die Fraktion
der cdu/csu hat beantragt über Ihren
Antrag auf Drucksache 36,90 abzustimmen
die Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wünschen Überweisung und zwar
federführend an den Ausschuss für Umwelt
Naturschutz nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz und mit beratend an
den Ausschuss für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft wir stimmen nach
ständiger Übung zunächst mal über die
Ausschuss Überweisungen ab und ich frage
deshalb wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Gründung
die FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
linke cdu/cs und die afd-enthaltung sehe
ich keine dann ist die Überweisung so
beschlossen damit stimmen wir heute über
den Antrag auf Drucksache 36,90 nicht in
der Sache ab und sie sind damit kommen
wir dann zum nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um Sanktionen die von der
Europäischen Union erlassen werden und
wie diese umgesetzt werden können noch
ist die Durchsetzung von Sanktionen in
den verschiedenen EU-Mitgliedstaaten
recht unterschiedlich und deswegen
möchte dort die Union das noch
harmonisieren und damit der deutsche
Vertreter im Rat der Europäischen Union
ist diesem diese Harmonisierung
zustimmen kann braucht es einen
Gesetzentwurf und über diesen
Gesetzentwurf sprechen wir jetzt das ist
die zweite und dritte Beratung des
Gesetzesentwurfes der hier von der
Bundesregierung eingebracht wurde und
der Titel ist Entwurf eines Beschlusses
des Rates über die Feststellung des
Verstoßes gegen restriktive Maßnahmen
der Union als einen die Kriterien nach
Artikel 83 Absatz 1 des Vertrages über
die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union
erfüllenden kriminalitätsbereich das zur
Vollständigkeit halber wie gesagt es
geht um Sanktionen gegen Unternehmen
Gruppen Organisationen oder
Einzelpersonen die zum Beispiel mit
Reisebeschränkungen belegt werden können
deren Vermögenswerte eingefroren werden
können oder zum Beispiel wo es um
Einfuhr oder Ausfuhrbeschränkungen geht
und der erste Redner dazu ist Michael
Sacher von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsident
entschuldigen Sie Herr Sacher das war
jetzt zu viel gerade Chaos auf einmal
ich möchte natürlich erwähnen dass das
ihre erste Rede in diesem Hause ist
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen als dezidierter
nicht-tourist spreche ich hier bei
diesem Thema als überzeugter Europäer
und nicht nur als Mitglied des
Ausschusses für europäische
Angelegenheiten als ein überzeugter
Europäer der auch mit Hilfe der
trockenen Rechtsprechung hofft die
Zukunft auf unserem Kontinent und
darüber hinaus friedlich und
prosperierend gestalten zu können
prosperierend ist hier allerdings nicht
in einem herkömmlichen vereinfachten
Sinne mit Wirtschaftswachstum zu
verwechseln sondern weiter darüber
hinaus als am blühendes gedeihen einer
vielfältigen Zivilgesellschaft zu
verstehen
wie schon das Sams in den Büchern von
Paul Maar bei dem Gebrauch von
Wunschpunkten einforderte genauestens
genau zu wünschen so ist das auch auf
dem Feld der Rechtsprechung wichtig und
wesentlich genau zu sein
nachzujustieren wenn sich Probleme bei
der Durchsetzung des gültigen rechtes
zeigen
die Europäische Kommission möchte
erreichen dass sie Verletzungen von
EU-Sanktionen zu Straftaten erklärt
werden um so die Verfolgung effektiver
zu gestalten
wir als Bundestag müssen dem zuvor
zustimmen das Verstöße gegen die von der
EU verhängten Sanktionen in den
kriminalitätsbereich übernommen werden
können so einfach so gut und darum geht
es hier
nicht unwesentlich ist vielleicht der
Hinweis dass Deutschland das letzte
europäische Land ist das hier noch auf
nationaler Ebene zustimmen muss
dies liegt diesmal nicht am langsamen
Internet sondern daran dass wir eines
der wenigen Parlamente sind überhaupt
damit befasst werden ein Zeichen unserer
starken parlamentarischen Demokratie
vor dem Hintergrund des Krieges den
Russland gegen die Ukraine führt ist
diese rechtliche Schwachstelle bei einem
Sanktionen noch einmal deutlich
hervorgetreten verbunden mit dem Problem
dass eine Harmonisierung des Strafmaßes
in den Mitgliedstaaten von Nöten ist
denn wenn dieses das Strafmaß in den
unterschiedlichen europäischen Ländern
von einigen tausend bis zu mehreren
hunderttausend Euro variiert lässt das
nicht nur Fachleute wie Laien staunen
sondern Zeug nicht gerade von einer gut
aufgestellten einheitlichen
Geschlossenheit
Sanktionen zu verhängen ist das eine sie
aber auch nachhaltig und effektiv
durchsetzen zu können das andere hier
nachzubessern ist notwendig und dringend
geboten
die expertinnenanhörung im Ausschuss hat
das einhellig und deutlich unterstrichen
nicht ohne auf die Schwierigkeiten im
Detail nämlich die Präzisierung zu
verweisen aber diese ist auch erst der
zweite Schritt auf europäischer Ebene
den wir heute durch unsere Beschluss
erst ermöglichen
es geht um eine vernünftige
nachvollziehbare Regulierung jetzt vor
allem rechtlich abgesichert werden muss
damit die Europäische Union in diesem
Punkt international handlungsfähig und
verlässlich bleiben kann
diese Regelung um es knapp zu sagen ist
einfach notwendig und wichtig und nur
der Teufel wird sicherlich noch im
Detail stecken wo zum Beispiel noch die
einzelnen Tatbestände rechtssicher und
wir erinnern uns genauestens genauso
definiert werden müssen
hier sei nur alle in diesem Haus
beruhigt denn diese Ausformulierung wird
erneut hier im Parlament verhandelt und
besprochen und dann erst auf dem
rechtsgültigen Weg gebracht
eingangs wie es sich schon darauf hin
dass ich an überzeugter Europäer bin ein
Umstand auf den hinzuweisen in diesen
Tagen vielleicht wieder notwendiger wird
als alle hier oder fast alle hier
gedacht und gehofft hatten
eine starke Gemeinschaft verträgt
durchaus Unruhen Aggression von innen
und außen kann darauf reagieren damit
diskursiv umgehen und nicht nur in der
Europäischen Union hilft Kritik häufig
einfach um besser zu werden so wie
Demokratie nie ein festgefügter
Endzustand ist sondern ein Prozess einen
immerwährendes aushandeln so ist es auch
mit der Europäischen Union
Vielstimmigkeit und Diversität ist dabei
unsere Stärke
stumpf mit dem nationalen Kopf durch die
Wand zu wollen oder vielmehr Fakten frei
mit diesem an die Wand zu schlagen ist
weder eine gute Strategie noch eine
konstruktive Politik
und es tut auch schon meistens beim
Zuschauen weh die Europäische Union wird
beständig von uns neu gestaltet und
hoffentlich Schritt für Schritt
verbessert und in jeweils aktuellen
Gegebenheiten angepasst wenn Kritik aber
in Hass umschläfen alles konstruktive
vermissen lässt und es nicht um eine
Verbesserung sondern einfach nur noch um
die Zerstörung geht dann ist ein Punkt
erreicht wo wir hier in unserem
Parlament in unserem Land in Europa und
in Brüssel für eines der stärksten
friedensprojekte kämpfen müssen
nicht kämpfen wie die Ukraine mit
schweren Waffen gegen einer Aggressor
von außen kämpfen muss sondern von innen
heraus kämpfen mit Überzeugung Fakten
und den Möglichkeiten die ein freies
miteinander bieten
Werte Kollegin nur in einem freien und
diversen miteinander werden wir uns für
eine gelingende Zukunft aufstellen
können in der Europäischen Union in der
wir unsere Konflikte regelbasiert und
ohne einen nationalistisches ich zuerst
lösen können
und manchmal
manchmal sind es eben vermeintlich
kleine juristische Maßnahmen die einen
nicht unwesentlichen Anteil an einem
Gelingen eines großen Kampfes für den
Frieden in Europa haben danke viel
das Wort erhält Katharina dos Santos
Vince für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit Putins Teil
mobil machen vor einer Woche sowie den
scheinreferenten in den von Russland
besetzten Gebieten hat der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine eine
neue Stufe erreicht als Reaktion darauf
hat die EU-Kommission gestern ein
Vorschlag für ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland vorgelegt
enthalten sind unter anderem weitere
Importbeschränkungen im Wert von um 7
Milliarden Euro sowie die
Rechtsgrundlage für einen preisdeckel
für Ölimporte aus Russland
neben neuen sanktionspaketen bedarf es
aber jedoch vor allem auch endlich eine
effektiveren Durchsetzung der bereits
bestehenden Sanktionen Sophie eine
Ahnung von Verstößen
aktuell bestehen zwischen den
sanktionsregimen der einzelnen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten signifikante
Unterschiede was deren Wirkkraft
insgesamt deutlich abschwächt so handelt
es sich in einigen Mitgliedsstaaten bei
Verstößen im ordnungswidrigkeitenbereich
in anderen Ländern um schwere Straftaten
die mit langen Freiheitsstrafen geahndet
werden
angesichts dieses unterschiedlichen
Umgangs der Mitgliedsstaaten mit
Sanktionen ist es höchste Zeit dass
sanktionsstrafrechts auf EU-Ebene zu
harmonisieren und so gewisse
Mindeststrafen bei Verstößen in allen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten zu gewährleisten wir
müssen
wir müssen als EU einheitlich und stark
reagieren können jede Umgehung von
Sanktionen jedes Schlupfloch schwächt
die Sicherheit die Verhandlungsbasis und
letztendlich auch die Reputation der EU
und jedes Mitgliedsstaat selbst
grundsätzlich liegt das Strafrecht in
der Kompetenz der Mitgliedstaaten
allerdings darf die EU nach 83 Absatz 1
AUV Mindestvorschriften von Straftaten
in Strafen mit besonders schwerwiegenden
kriminalitätsbereichen festlegen die
eine grenzüberschreitende Dimension
haben das gilt zum Beispiel schon für
den Bereich der Geldwäsche wodurch
komplexe grenzüberschreitende
Verflechtungen eine länderübergreifende
Strafverfolgung und Zusammenarbeit
sinnvoll und notwendig ist im Mai diesen
Jahres hat die EU-Kommission den
Vorschlag für einen Beschluss des Rates
vorgelegt der auch das
sanktionsstrafrecht umfasst und aufgrund
seiner grenzüberschreitenden Dimensionen
in die Liste der kriminalitätsbereiche
aufzunehmen ist aus meiner Sicht ein
absolut wichtiger und richtiger Schritt
mir ist es an dieser Stelle aber noch
mal wichtig zu betonen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag sich auch in kurzer Zeit
intensiv in dieses Thema eingearbeitet
hat und zu den Themen beraten hat sowohl
in unserer Fraktion als auch in den
entsprechenden Gremien zuletzt gestern
im Europaausschuss und am Montag in der
öffentlichen Anhörung so werden wir
unser
integrationsverantwortung auch deutlich
und umfassend gerecht
der vollgelegte entsetztesentwurf
enthält zur Überraschung vieler auch ein
Passus zum Infektionsschutzgesetz wie
kommen wir jetzt vom AUV zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz aufgrund des
omnirus-verfahrens wie in einem Bus
bildlich gesprochen kommt in unserem
Fall ein weiterer Passagier in den Bus
dazu und wir fahren gemeinsam durch
dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahren in diesem
Fall geht es um eine Änderung im
Infektionsschutzgesetz auf Druck der
unionsgeführten Länder hat der Bundesrat
vor zwei Wochen nun entschieden dass
nach einer überstandenen
corona-infektionen keine testpflicht für
Kinder Jugendliche und Beschäftigte bei
der Rückkehr in Schulen Kitas und
Einrichtungen der Kinder- und
Jugendhilfe geben sollen die zu einer
stärkeren Belastung der vorgenannten
Personengruppe geführt hätte Erwachsene
können schließlich auch nach einer
entsprechenden
überstandenen corona-infektion ohne
negativen Test zurück zu ihrem
arbeitsplatzkern wir begrüßen daher
ausdrücklich diese Streichung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zurück zu
unserem Gesetzentwurf zu den Sanktionen
wie sieht das weitere Verfahren aus wird
der Beschluss des Rates angenommen kann
die EU-Kommission in einem zweiten
Schritt eine konkrete Richtlinie für
eine EU-weite Mindestharmonisierung von
Sanktionen vorliegen die dann wiederum
wie schon erwähnt in nationales Gesetz
und gerecht umgesetzt werden muss wenn
es im nächsten Schritt dann in die
nationale Umsetzung geht ist es mein
Wunsch und Anliegen eine enge Abstimmung
auf nationaler Ebene zwischen der
Mitgliedstaaten zu fördern und dazu
gehört für mich auch eine enge
Abstimmung unter dem Parlamentariern in
den verschiedenen Foren die wir dafür
haben ein gutes Beispiel und das wäre
mir wirklich ein Herzensanliegen in
dieser Sache ist ein gemeinsamer
Austausch auch mit den französischen
Kollegen in der deutsch-französischen
Parlamentarischen Versammlung in jedem
Fall wird uns dieses Thema auch auf
parlamentarischer Ebene noch eine
längere Zeit begleiten wir sehen uns
also wieder herzlichen Dank
Katharina das Santos Vinz war das für
die Unionsfraktion und nächster Redner
ist Fabian Funke Mitglied der
SPD-Fraktion und Mitglied im Ausschuss
für Angelegenheiten Europäischen Union
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren was hinter diesen
zugegebenermaßen etwas
verwaltungsdeutsch und kompliziert
klingt ein Tagesordnungspunkt steht ist
ein weiteres wichtiges Signal der
Unterstützung der Ukraine gegen den
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg der
Russischen Föderation die letzten Monate
haben gezeigt dass wir gemeinsam als
Europäische Union stark sein können wenn
wir geschlossen agieren das haben wir
bei der politischen Unterstützung der
Ukraine gesehen das haben wir bei der
materiellen Unterstützung der Ukraine
gesehen und das haben wir auch bei den
Sanktionen immer gesehen auch wenn es
manchmal schwer war Einigkeit unter den
Mitgliedsstaaten herzustellen auch weil
die Gegebenheiten und Abhängigkeiten so
unterschiedlich sind hier in Deutschland
haben wir mit dem
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz bereits
national die Voraussetzungen geschaffen
die Vorstöße die Verstöße gegen die
Sanktionen entsprechend zu ahnten mit
der Änderung des Artikel 83 AEUV
schaffen wir sie auch europäisch doch
was genau verbirgt sich dahinter
mit der Befähigung der Bundesregierung
zur Zustimmung der Änderung des Artikel
83 Absatz 1 im Europäischen Rat fügen
wir dem Katalog grenzüberschreitender
europäischer einheitlicher Bekämpfung
von Kriminalität einen neuen
kriminalitätsbereich hinzu Verstöße
gegen die eu-sanktionsbeschlüsse dieser
Schritt ermöglicht uns gemeinsame
europäische Mindeststandards für die
Strafen bei Verstößen gegen die
Sanktionen festzulegen wir werden
Schluss machen mit den Dutzenden
unterschiedlichen nationalstaatlichen
organisierten Sanktionsregime wir legen
das Fundament dafür dass künftig
sanktionsbeschlüsse das Ende nicht der
Anfang von umsetzungsdebatten sind
wir machen dem russischen Receiver
deutlich hier handeln 27 Staaten von der
Atlantikküste bis zur ukrainischen
Grenze als Einheit die sanktionsverstöße
in den Katalog aufzunehmen ist im
übrigen auch ein mustergültiges Beispiel
für die Anwendung des Artikel 33 denn
sie erfüllen die beiden
ausschlaggebenden Kriterien dafür
außerordentlich sie repräsentieren einen
besonders schweren kriminalitätsbereich
und haben eine grenzüberschreitende
Dimension denn welches Verbrechen könnte
schwerer wiegen als unsere gemeinsamen
Bemühungen zufrieden und Freiheit in
Europa wieder herzustellen und welcher
Tatbestand könnte grenzüberschreitender
sein als beispielsweise mit Verstößen
gegen die Finanzsanktionen
hier bei uns die Kriegsmaschinerie in
Russland zu finanzieren die besondere
Notwendigkeit diese Kriminalität auf
einer gemeinsamen Grundlage zu bekämpfen
ist offensichtlich aber scheinbar nicht
offensichtlich genug denn abgesehen von
der Opposition ganz rechts hier im
Plenum und leider Gottes auch Teilen der
Opposition ganz links im Plenum auf die
ich eigentlich auch gar nicht weiter
eingehen möchte weil es auch nichts
bringt gibt es derzeit ja immer noch
eine laute Stimme auch aus der Mitte
dieses Parteienspektrums
dies auch nach sieben Monaten an
Gräueltaten immer noch nicht verstanden
hat und anders sieht und gerade als
Abgeordneter aus Sachsen ist es mir
deshalb besonders wichtig nochmal
grundsätzlich ein paar Worte zu den
Sektionen und ihre Wichtigkeit zu
verlieren Russland führt seit sieben
Monaten einen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine die russische Armee begeht
systematisch Kriegsverbrechen gegen die
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung Russland
finanziert seit Jahren in Europa
rechtsradikale Bewegungen Parteien und
Kandidaten Russland arbeitet aktiv an
der Destabilisierung unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
durch massive des Informationskampagnen
die europäischen Sanktionen sind unsere
Reaktion darauf die hohen Gaspreise die
blockierten Lebensmittellieferungen die
versiegelten Pipelines das sind alles
Druckmittel der russischen Regierung mit
der sie nur eins erreichen will dass wir
alles durchgehen lassen dass wir nicht
mal den Versuch unternehmen unsere
Demokratie zu verteidigen doch darauf
lassen wir uns nicht ein die
Energiekrise die Preiserhöhungen die
gestörten Lieferketten das alles ist die
Konsequenz des russ der Handels und
nicht die Konsequenz unserer Reaktion
darauf wir reagieren mit
entlastungspaketen und der
gaspreisbremse um die Folgen für unsere
Bevölkerung abzufedern Liebe CDU ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen ausdrücklich für
die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit im
Bereich der Ukraine Hilfe und auch die
Unterstützung dieser Beschlussempfehlung
sowohl bei der Anhörung im Munde am
Montag als auch im Ausschuss aber
erklären Sie mir bitte wie so ein
amtierender christdemokratischer
Ministerpräsident und stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender die Sanktionen
mittlerweile nahezu täglich und
ausgiebig in Interviews und öffentlichen
Auftritten in Frage stellt mit einem
Duktus der aussagt man müsse am Ende nur
mal richtig der Diplomatie machen und
dann wird alles wieder in Ordnung das
ist naiv und falsch
das schwächt die deutsche Position in
Europa das schwächt die europäische
Position gegenüber Russland und das
sorgt dafür dass ich Putin nachts im
Kreml ins Häuschen macht auch die
schlimmen Äußerung ihres fraktions- und
Parteivorsitzenden Friedrich Merz in
dieser Woche die ich ehrlich gesagt von
der AFD erwartet hätte aber nicht von
ihnen haben das nicht besser gemacht
gerade in Ostdeutschland wissen wir was
Autokratie und fremdbestimmungen aus
Moskau bedeutet die Stasi Enteignung und
fehlende Grundrechte das alles kam aus
dem Handbuch Moskau in dich erwarte von
einem sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten
erst recht wenn er offenkundlicher für
ganz Ostdeutschland sprechen möchte dass
er in dieser aktuellen Lage Solidarität
mit unseren zentralen und
osteuropäischen Partnern zeigt mit denen
wir so viel mehr historischer
Gemeinsamkeiten Teilen ich freue mich
dass seine und ihre Parteifreundinnen
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
gestern das nächste Sanktionspaket
vorgelegt hat und ich habe großes
Vertrauen in die Bundesregierung dass
wir die Bürgerinnen und Bürger im
kommenden Winter weiter von den Effekten
putins-
werden wir schaffen das nur gemeinsam in
Europa zu guter Letzt noch ein paar
Worte zur Änderung des § 34
Infektionsschutzgesetz der ja jetzt auch
Teil dieses Tagesordnungspunktes ist mit
diesem Änderungsantrag kommen wir der
breit getragenen bitte der Bundesländer
nach die testlich für Schulkinder nach
einer corona-infektion zu streichen mit
der Aufnahme in diesem Gesetzentwurf
stellen wir auch sicher dass die
Änderung pünktlich die
bundesratssitzungen am 7.12.2022
erreicht und das ist gut so vielen Dank
fabian funkewaner ist für die
SPD-Fraktion auf ihn folgt nun Fabian
Jacobi Mitglied der afd-fraktion und im
Ausschuss für Recht und
Verbraucherschutz
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
dass man keine Krise ungenutzt
vorbeigehen lassen sollte das ist ein
alter und allgemein anerkannter
Grundsatz auch die EU hat sich diesem
Prinzip verschrieben zuletzt hat man die
Krise der sogenannten Pandemie genutzt
um unter ihrem Deckmantel das
Verschuldungsverbot der EU zu kippen
seitdem nimmt die EU selber Schulden auf
für die am Ende die Mitgliedstaaten und
natürlich vor allem Deutschland haften
jetzt haben wir die Krise des russischen
Krieges gegen die Ukraine und auch diese
bleibt natürlich nicht ungenutzt
vielmehr dient sie als willkommener
Vorwand um den Parlamenten der
Mitgliedsstaaten weitere strafrechtliche
Gesetzgebungskompetenzen zu entziehen
wir als afd-fraktion lehnen das
selbstverständlich schon aus
grundsätzlichen Erwägungen ab
die fortlaufende Aufgabe weiterer Teile
unserer staatlichen Souveränität ist ein
schwerer Fehler und der Umstand dass
diejenigen die solche staatszersetzung
betreiben gleichzeitig mit diesem
Schlagwort auf uns zeigen die wir uns
dagegen wehren ist ein ganz schlechter
Scherz
wir sind aber nicht nur aus abstrakten
Gründen dagegen auch im konkreten bietet
der Vorgang mehr als genug Anlass zur
Ablehnung der Weg der hier gegangen
werden soll führt über die
brückenklausel in Artikel 83 des
auvertrages der hat einige Waage
gehaltene formale Voraussetzungen und um
uns bestätigen zu lassen dass es nicht
bereits daran scheitert haben wir am
Montag in EU-Ausschuss extra noch ganz
kurzfristig eine Anhörung abgehalten
hinterher war in den Hausmitteilungen
des Bundestages zu lesen die
Sachverständigen hätten allesamt
bescheinigt es sei alles ganz wunderbar
nun ja die mündlichen Äußerungen sind
das eine hilfreicher sind manchmal die
schriftlichen Ausführungen der
Sachverständigen den lassen sich gute
Gründe für erhebliche Bedenken entnehmen